estell als wenn wir hier das Land
ruinieren würden und zwar das Zitat die
Unternehmer in Deutschland hätten das
Vertrauen in die Bundesregierung
verloren Zitat Ende und das sagte nich
der Arbeitgeber Präsident reiner Dulger
der fazaz und muss sagen auch bei Ihnen
auf der Regierungsbank sollten
mittlerweile die Alarmsignale doch
längst angekommen sein wo bleibt
eigentlich her Bundeskanzler ihr Respekt
von dem sie ja im Wahlkampf so viel
gesprochen haben gegenüber den Bauern
und B die über Generationen hin weeg
hier diesen Wirtschaftsmotor Deutschland
am Laufen gehalten haben und wenn man
keinen Respekt hat und hat dann liebt
man dieses Land auch nicht und das
zeigen sie jeden Tag mit ihrer
Bundesregierung und es sind eben genau
die Menschen die uns alle hier gewählt
haben um eine Politik für Deutschland zu
machen sie machen Politik aber für wen
machen Sie eigentlich Politik Frau
Hasselmann für die Beratungsunternehmen
und die Millionen schweren Verträge im
Rahmen der Energiewende für ihre
Rüstungslobby für diese Menschen ist
Milliarden Euro an Geld da aber nicht
für die einfachen Bürger für diejenigen
die jeden Tag hart arbeiten und meine
Damen und Herren jeder Steuereuro muss
erstmal verdient werden erst dann können
wir hier darüber entscheiden wo er gut
investiert werden kann und ich kann nur
sagen dass ihre Schwerpunkte eben nicht
nachvollziehbar sind denn die
Wirtschaftlage wirtschaftliche Lage in
Deutschland sie ist desolat dazu einige
Eckpunkte Deutschland ist der der
einzige G7 Staat ohne
Wirtschaftswachstum Deutschland ist im Z
Halbjahr 2023 in eine Rezession
gerutscht die Gründe dafür sind hohe
Energiekosten die grüne Transformation
und schlechte Standortbestimmungen die
Ernsthaftigkeit der Lage ist offens
sichtlich warum reduzieren sie selbst
als Bundesregierung und auch das
ifointitut bereits die
wirtschaftswachstumserwartung für
2024 und ja jetzt kommen sie wieder mit
den internationalen Märkten und die
Kriege die wir leider wieder zu beklagen
haben zu diesen haben wir als
Alternative für Deutschland unsere
Position oft genug dargelegt wir
brauchen Frieden und wir wie auch die
Bürger wollen keinen Kampf mehr von
Systemen und von Ideologien und genau
diese Kriege sind eben nicht
verantwortlich dafür dass sie als
Bundesregierung die von Ihnen selbst
verursachten Standortnachteile weiter in
Kauf nehmen schauen sie endlich über den
Tellerrand hinaus auch wenn es
anstrengend ist und sicherlich wie sie
auch enttäuschend ist die Firmen wandern
ab oder wollen abwandern und wenn man
als Unternehmer ständig rote Zahlen
schreibt gibt es nicht die Möglichkeit
mehr Ausgaben als Einnahmen zu
verursachen ein Unternehmer muss sich
auch an geltende Gesetze halten und kann
sie nicht einfach umgehen das kann nur
diese Bundesregierung indem sie die
Schuldenbremse die vor staatsverfolgung
zu schützen sein soll einfach aussetzt
bei dieser wirtschaftlichen Bilanz ist
das verantwortungslos und vor allen
Dingen staatsschädigend und wir haben es
gesehen im letzten Haushalt
verfassungswidrig was sie hier in diesem
Land
betreiben Werte Kollegen die deutsche
Wirtschaft lebt von Exporten und guten
wirtschaftlichen Beziehung in allen
Ländern darüber sind wir uns denke ich
in diesem Haus einig aber nun brechen
selbst die Exporte nach China und in die
USA ein wie kann sich eigentlich die
Arbeit für die Bürger überhaupt noch
lohnen wenn die Grundlage genommen wird
wie viele wollen sie in die
Alimentierung durch den Staat eigentlich
noch treiben für einige scheint sich
mittlerweile Erwerbsarbeit dank
bürgerkeld kaum noch zu lohnen und bei
all diesen Befunden senden sie als
ampelakteure weder Demut noch Einsicht
aus dafür treiben sie einen Spalt weiter
in die Gesellschaft und vor allen Dingen
sie drehen die Verantwortung um das ist
eigentlich der absolute Hammer den wir
aktuell hier erleben der
Bundesfinanzminister Linder sprach am
Wochenende davon das Programm der AFD
würde Deutschland wirtschaftlich
ruinieren und Herr lickt nach die AFD
sei Gift für den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland sehen sie eigentlich nicht
wer das wirkliche Gift in diesem Land
ist das sehen die Bürger jeden Tag indem
sie ihre Rechnung nicht mehr bezahlen
können indem immer mehr Unternehmen
pleite gehen indem immer mehr
Unternehmen abwandern und immer mehr
Bürger die Nase gestrichen voll haben
von den Bauern von den Handwerkern und
von Mittelstand in diesem Land sehr
geehrte Damen und
Herren stellen sie sich H hin und beten
wieder das große Lied der Demokratie nie
wieder ist jetzt da gebe ich ihn recht
nie wieder ist jetzt auch inem man
staatskonforme Medienhäuser quasi als
zweite stasie aufbaut und gegen die
Opposition einsetzt auch das ist nie
wieder jetzt das hatten wir alles schon
und das erinnert an die dunkelsten
Zeiten unserer Geschichte und wir sind
nicht nervös die einzigen die nervös
sind das sind sie und die SPD vor allem
wenn ich an die Wahlen dieses Jahr in
Deutschland denke an die Europawahl an
die Landtagswahl in Sachsen brandenbrück
und Thüringen sie bekommen die Quittung
und zwar vom Souverän vom deutschen
Bürger und darauf freue ich mich darauf
freue ich
mich hätten sie wirklich in dieser
ganzen Debatte und Kampagne mit
Korrektiv hätten sie diese Leute noch
mal recherchieren lassen bei kumex oder
bei nordstream da erwarten wir Ergebnis
hier im Parlament die sie immer noch
schuldig geblieben sind wer diese
Terrorakte durchgeführt hat genauso die
Geldverschwendung und bei diesen ganzen
Problemen die kumex verursacht hat in
diesem Sinne meine Damen und Herren
Werte Kollegen sage ich einst die
deutsche Wirtschaft lebt von den
Exporten und guten wirtschaftlichen
Beziehung und wir als AFD werden da uns
dafür wieder einsetzen dass Deutschland
als Wirtschaftsstandort attraktiv ist
und dass Deutschland vor allen Dingen
endlich wieder das verdient was es hat
eine ordentliche und vernünftige
Regierung vielen Dank
tinoopaler Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD in der
Generaldebatte des Deutschen Bundestages
die seit 12 Uhr läuft und die auch noch
mindestens eine Stunde laufen wird und
hier sehr intensiv beobachtet wird von
vielen Gästen auf der Besuchertribüne
unter anderem haben wir vorhin gesehen
Gäste aus Würzburg Karnevalisten sind
hier von einem Traditionsverein die
demnächst richtig Fasching feiern aber
heute erst
informen andre Pult für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen einer der
stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Verfassung und wir
haben es glaube ich in zwei reden heute
hier gesehen in der Rede von Frau Weidel
in der Rede von Herrn krupaler Feinde
unserer liberalen Demokratie die die
Pfeiler unseres Grundgesetzes die
Freiheit und die Gleichheit aller
Menschen offen in Frage
stellen wir haben viel über das Treffen
indam gehört nicht nur das weil wir es
auch ansonsten sehr sehr offensichtlich
auf dem Tisch haben 20 bis 30% der
Bevölkerung will Björn höcke aus dem
Land schaffen so hat er es im dezember
2023 gesagt die Videos sind online jeder
kann es sehen jeder kann es wissen man
möchte man muss es nur wissen wollen und
um den Kampf um unsere Demokratie
erfolgreich führen zu können brauchen
wir alle in diesem Land wir brauchen als
erstes brauch wir starke
Sicherheitsbehörden die zu hinschauen
die die zuschauen was passiert und
dokumentieren was los ist wir brauchen
als zweites Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler die herausarbeiten z.B
dass ihre Partei das Umfeld ihrer Partei
um konkret zu sein das Umfeld von
bertrix von Storch ganz konkret von
Russland finanziert wurde dreimal wurde
ich verklagt von dem Umfeld ihrer Partei
weil ich das offen sage dreimal haben
Gerichte bestätigt dreimal haben sie
gesagt ich sage es zurecht ich sag's
hier noch mal sie das Umfeld ihrer
Partei wird finanziert von Oligarchen
aus Putins
Russland wir brauchen diese
Wissenschaftler wir brauchen aber auch
die freie Presse die aufdeckt was da los
ist bei Ihnen und dass sie genau das
hier wieder in Frage Gestellen zeigt wie
wichtig das ist wir brauchen die freie
Presse wenn sie sich mit rechtsextremen
treffen wenn Sie die Deportation von
Millionen von Menschen Plan ganz konkret
durch deklinieren und wir brauchen nicht
zuletzt Hunderttausende von Menschen auf
den Straßen um sicherzustellen dass Sie
nicht die Deutungshoheit über unsere
Gesellschaft erlangen können deswegen
bin ich so dankbar über die Mitte der
Gesellschaft die sich aufgemacht hat
genau das jetzt auch ganz öffentlich
deutlich zu machen ich bin dankbar für
350 000 Menschen in Berlin über 100.000
in Düsseldorf und in Hamburg aber ich
bin fast noch beeindruckter über 5000
Menschen in Düren über 4000 Menschen in
Singen über 1500 Menschen in saahfeld
über die 500 Menschen in Luckenwalde
über die 400 Menschen in Spremberg all
das sind Menschen die ganz klar sagen
wir stehen auf gegen diesen
Rechtsextremismus und dass sie es jetzt
versuchen als großstadtphänomen als von
der Regierung gesteuert darzustellen
zeigt wie viel Angst sie haben zeigt wie
nervös sie sind dass für sie jeden Tag
deutlicher wird dass das nicht weiter
akzeptiert wird und dass jeden Tag
deutlicher wird dass sie aufs engste
zusammenarbeiten rechtsextreme
identitäre Leute aus der AFD und ihre
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
zusammen am Tisch zusammen planend das
was dieses Land zu Grunde richten soll
das was wir heute morgen beklagt haben
was sie jetzt wieder ganz konkret planen
und ein zweiter Grund es gibt einen
zweiten Grund warum sie so nervös sind
weil eine These gebrochen wurde nämlich
dass die rechtsextreme in diesem Land
die Mehrheit der Menschen stellen das
wollen sie weis machen das Gegenteil ist
bewiesen hundertausende gehen auf die
Straße um deutlich zu machen diese These
trifft nicht zu die Mehrheit unseres
Landes lehnt diesen Rechtsextremismus
entschieden ab heute sagen wir nie
wieder und wer sagt nie wieder der muss
wissen was damals war das ist die
Voraussetzung dafür deswegen haben an
die Greultaten des Nationalsozialismus
erinnert und deswegen sorgen wir mit
diesem Haushalt mit dem was wir tun dass
in ganz Deutschland stetig daran
erinnert werden kann wir haben bereits
im letzten Jahr ein großes Paket über 80
Millionen Euro gepackt um die KZ
Gedenkstätten in Deutschland stärker zu
unterstützen und wir haben jetzt in
diesem Haushalt noch mal nachgelegt noch
mal Geld zur Verfügung gestellt so haben
wir z.B die Gedenkstätten stätdte
deutscher Widerstand die Stiftung denk
mal für die ermordeten Juden Europas die
Stiftung niedersächsische gedenkstätdten
Bergen Belsen und andere mit noch mal
knapp 2 Millionen Euro gestärkt weil wir
wissen wie notwendig es ist dass ich
Menschen in ganz Deutschland mit diesen
Fragen
auseinandersetzen und wir stärken mit
dem was wir machen kulturelles Leben in
ganz Deutschland mit dem
amateurmusikfond von der blaskabelle
Kapelle bis zum Musikfest in ganz
Deutschland mit dem Festival förderfond
ebenfalls
wirter weiter das UNESCO welterbeche
Zollverein weil uns diese Geschichte
wichtig ist die aufrecht zuerhalten und
gleichzeitig das Haus der Kulturen der
Welt und das Heimaten Festival weil dort
aufgearbeitet und gezeigt wird dass es
Heimat in Deutschland gibt und zwar im
Plural in Vielfalt weil wir alle
gemeinsam hier zusammen leben danke
[Applaus]
Ihnen stellvereter vorsit deraktion die
Grünen in der Generaldebatte und jetzt
haben wir mal zusammengerechnet die
Redner die wir hier im Moment auf der
Liste haben da kommen wir schon auf
locker noch 73 Minuten aber jetzt
erstmal Bijan jersarai ist in der FDP
und der Generalsekretär der Partei das
Vortragen von Zahlen das haben wir heute
gesehen es geht in erster Linie um die
Politik die dahinter steht und diese
Politik muss immer im Einklang mit der
Realität im Land sein und wie sieht
diese Realität aus wir haben enorme
wirtschaftspolitische Herausforderung
wir haben enorme finanzpolitische
Herausforderung in unserem Land das
Thema Migration wird uns noch eine ganze
Weile beschäftigen und wir haben
zentrale außen und sicherheitspolitische
Fragen die wir noch in diesem Jahr
beantworten müssen es ist schon mehrmals
heute angesprochen was passiert wenn wir
Ende dieses Jahres oder Anfang nächsten
Jahres möglicherweise im Weißen Haus
einen anderen Präsidenten haben einen
Präsidenten der uns dann sagt be
bepielsweise der Krieg in der Ukraine
kümmert euch liebe Europäer selbst liebe
Europäer kümmert euch selbst um die
Sicherheitsarchitektur in Europa das hat
ja nicht nur außen und
sicherheitspolitische folgen sondern
eine mögliche Präsidentschaft von Herrn
Trump hätte auch Handels und
wirtschaftspolitische folgen und
deswegen ist das auch außerordentlich
wichtig dass wir in Deutschland und
Europa auf diese Herausforderung
vorbereitet wenn
wir
schwierigen Situation ein starkes Land
bleiben wollen und den Wohlstand in
unserem Land bewahren und mehren wollen
dann müssen wir dringend den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland stärken
und Deutschland wieder fit für die
Zukunft machen der wirtschaftliche
Erfolg unseres Landes ist von zentraler
Bedeutung für unsere Zukunft meine Damen
und Herren und ich will ihnen das auch
an dieser Stelle ganz klar sagen wer wer
ökologische Transformation will
werunktion
funktionierende soziale
Sicherungssysteme will muss die
Rahmenbedingung dafür schaffen dass die
Menschen Unternehmen und Betriebe in
unserem Land in erster Linie entlastet
werden und nicht belastet
werden vielleicht hat es der eine oder
andere in der Politik auch vergessen
aber wir erinnern gerne daran es muss
erst erwirtschaftet werden bevor
überhaupt verteilt werden kann meine
Damen
und ich
willit in diesem Zusammenhang eine
solide Finanzpolitik ist wir haben heute
Inflation im Euroraum wir haben eine
andere Zinsentwicklung als noch vor
einigen Jahren wir haben Krieg in Europa
wer in dieser schwierigen Situation eine
Schuldenpolitik will beschädigt den
Wirtschafts und Finanzstandort
Deutschland und macht einen großen
politischen
Fehler alles
muss alles muss heutzutage in
Deutschland nachhaltig sein das ist auch
gut so aber erstaunlicherweise wird
gerne in der Politik vergessen dass auch
Finanzpolitik nachhaltig sein muss das
heißt keine Belastungen für für die
Zukunft und keine Schuldenpolitik auf
Kosten künftiger Generation meine Damen
und
Herren wir dürfen keine Kosten keine
Schulden machen auf kostenkünftiger
Generation auf Schuldenbergen kann man
keine Zukunft bauen und er recht nicht
die Krisen dieser Zeit lösen und meine
Damen und Herren das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hat
selbstverständlich einiges ändert dieses
Urteil bedeutet aber lieber Rolf mützeen
nicht nicht dass wir die Schuldenbremse
umgehen dieses Urteil bedeutet auch
nicht dass wir die Schuldenbremse
Schleifen sondern dieses Urteil bedeutet
dass wir die Schuldenbremse in diesem
Land Stärken lieber Rolf und das ist die
zentrale Botschaft des
[Applaus]
Urteils und ich will dir das auch ganz
klar sagen lieber Rolf weil wir uns auch
sehr lange kenne und dich auch sehr
schätze aber es ist schon bemerkenswert
die Einhaltung der Schulden brse steht
auch so im Koalitionsvertrag
gelegentlich ist es auch gut sich den
Koalitionsvertrag anzuschauen und sich
hier hinzustellen und einfach Herrn märz
ein Angebot zu machen über die Umgehung
der Schuldenbremse zu reden finde ich
bemerkenswert lieber
Rolf wir sind wir sind beide
reheinländer ich habe sehr viel
Verständnis für die Art des Humors hier
und von daher ist es alles in Ordnung
geschenkt alles geschenkt meine Damen
und Herren meine Damen und Herren
ich will ich will aber an dieser Stelle
noch mal eine Sache deutlich machen denn
das wird immer der Unterschied bleiben
zwischen uns wir haben ein anderes
Staatsverständnis als ihr und das ist
der Unterschied das ist der große
Unterschied für uns ist das Geld des
Steuer Steuerzahlers nicht eine
beliebige verteilungsmasse für uns ist
es übrigens auch nicht das Geld des
Staates sondern das Geld der bürgerinn
und Bürger und das ist der große
Unterschied und wenn wir sagen solide
Finanzpolitik
und wenn wir sagen solide Finanzpolitik
dann heißt es in erster Linie Respekt
vor der Leistung der Steuerzahlerin und
Steuerzahler in diesem Land das muss
auch gelegentlich wieder in diesem Haus
deutlicher gesagt
werden meine Damen und Herren der
nächste Haushalt wird kommen die
nächsten intensive Debatten stehen auch
vor der Tür wir werden uns für die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse einsetzen
und wir werden Steuererhöhungen
bekämpfen und vermeiden wir sind seit
vielen Jahren in Deutschland ein
hochsteuerland Ja wenn Sie mir das nicht
glauben ich kann ihn nur empfehlen sich
dort die die Tabellen der oscd
anzuschauen wir sind seit vielen Jahren
in Deutschland ein hochsteuerland in
diesem Land sind die Belastungen für die
Menschen für die Betriebe für die
Unternehmen außerordentlich hoch und wer
in dieser Situation eine Schuldenpolitik
macht macht nicht nur einen Fehler
sondern das ist gerade Gift für den
Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und ich will auch an der
Stelle noch einmal weil das ja auch eine
haushaltspolitische Debatte ist der
deutsche Staat hat keine
einnahmeprobleme das Problem sind die
Ausgaben meine Damen und Herren und da
müssen wir ran und wenn wir und wenn wir
über die Ausgaben reden dann müssen wir
selbstverständlich auch über das Thema
Haushaltskonsolidierung reden und ich
will euch noch eine Sache sagen wenn ich
schon hier vorne stehe wir werden auch
emsam über die Zukunft des Sozialstaates
reden müssen denn das ist eine zentrale
Frage der sozialen Gerechtigkeit in
diesem Land der Moderne funktionierende
Sozialstaat darf nicht nur gerecht sein
gegenüber denjenigen die die Hilfe
brauchen sondern auch gerecht sein
finanzieren meine Damen und Herren
vielen
Dank ist bundestagmglied im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss hat hier natürlich eher in der
Rolle des Generalsekretär sein Partei
gesprochen und das ist ja hier die
generelle Generaldebatte wo
normalerweise Opposition und Koalition
aufeinander prallen aber in den
vergangenen Minuten haben wir auch
festgestellt dass es innerhalb der
Koalition den einen oder anderen
Unterschied in der Auffassung zu
diversen Politikfeldern gibt ich sage
nur Schuldenregel da ist die FDP
ganzlich andere Auffassung als Grüne und
SPD und auch beim Thema Kinderfreibetrag
und Kindergeld das ist ein Thema das
Rolf Mütze nicht in diese Debatte
reingetragen hatte wer wir
möglicherweise auch noch den einen oder
anderen Widerspruch aus den Reihen der
FDP hören vielleicht aber auch nicht
ktin Radomski spricht jetzt für die
Fraktion CDU CSO und sie ist die erste
von mehreren Mitgliedern des
Haushaltsausschusses die jetzt in der
nästen
Zeit re im Bereich der Kultur bleibt die
Filmförderung ein
Sorgenkind die Filmindustrie fordert
seit 2022 eine dringend benötigte und
dem versprochene Reform aber statt eine
Reform in Angriff zu nehmen wird
weiterhin an Symbolpolitik festgehalten
wie dem sogenannten green culture diese
Fokussierung auf symbolische Maßnahmen
lenkt von den eigentlichen
Herausforderung ab die der
Kulturstandort Deutschland gegenwärtig
zu bewältigen hat der erste Leitfaden
aus dem Green cultcher desk zuur
Theaterproduktion zeigt bereits was
Betreiber von Theaterbauten techn
empfohlen wird es wird empfohlen auf
Bewegungsmelder und Zeitschalter für die
Beleuchtung umzusteigen bei Wärmepumpen
soll auf Luftwärmepumpen anstatt
Erdwärmepumpen umgestallt werden das
Dach soll begrünt werden Regenwasser
soll aufgefangen werden und auf
kondensationswasser soll geachtet werden
diese technischen Maßnahmen sind
sicherlich gut im Baubereich aufgehoben
aber sie haben tatsächlich überhaupt
nichts mit Kultur im engeren Sinne zu
tun und und das große Ziel dieser
Regulierung scheint der gesamte
kulturelle Sektor zu sein wir haben
daher gefordert dass der Ansatz green
culture desk bei der Staatsministerin
gestrichen wird die Koalition hat das
abgelehnt nun zur Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für Migration
Flüchtlinge und Integration sowie
Antirassismus die Vielfalt ihrer
Aufgabenbereiche ist beeindruckend und
beeindruckend sind auch die Ausgaben für
die
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
750.000 € für das kommende Jahr und nach
eigenen Angaben hat die Staatsministerin
im Jahr 20 23 40% dieser Mittel für
Social Media Aktivitäten
genutzt schaut man sich das einmal
genauer an stellt man fest zwei bis drei
Posts pro Woche sind glaube ich eine
eher unterdurchschnittliche
Aktivität auch
es geht noch weiter auch bei der
Pressearbeit kann man die
Staatsministerin als ehermäßig aktiv
bezeichnen mit einer bis maximal zwei
Pressemitteilungen pro Monat im letzten
halben Jahr das und das bei einer
Staatsministerin die einen so wichtigen
und umfassenden Aufgabenbereich
betreut im Dezember fällt dann eine
Pressemitteilung mit dem Titel
kontrollquittung schafft mehr
Transparenz bei der Bundespolizei Auge
zur Erklärung für alle Anwesenden
künftig haben alle von der Bundespolizei
kontrollierten das Recht auf eine
sogenannte
kontrollquittung warum die Bundespolizei
kontrolliert beispielsweise in Zügen
Bahnhöfen oder an Flughäfen das schafft
nach Meinung der Staatsministerin
transparent gegen rassistische
Vorurteile und
Diskriminierung liebe Frau
Staatsministerin leider sind sie nicht
anwesend aber vielleicht können die
Kollegen aus dem Kanzleramt Ihnen das
mitteilen ich bin der Meinung dass
Rassismus
entschuldigung wo ist sie also schreien
sie doch nicht so rein die ist doch gar
nicht anwesend so ich bin der Meinung
dass rassissmus und Diskriminierung in
diesem Land keinen Platz haben dürfen
die von ihnen gelobte kontrollquittung
schafft keine Transparenz sondern
Bürokratie und letzten Endes ein
Misstrauen gegen die Bundespolizei
und wenn sie sich dann auch noch rühmen
eine wissenschaftliche Evaluation für
diese Maßnahme umgesetzt zu haben dann
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen das ist
schaufensterpitik der
Sonderklasse wenn Sie selbst am Ende der
pressemiststeilung nämlich feststellen
die meisten kontrollen finden gar nicht
durch die Bundespolizei statt sondern
durch die
Landespolizei und kommen wir am Ende ich
muss mich ja Beilen frau Präsidentin zum
Etat des Bundeskanzlers der mit 200
Millionen angesetzt ist und allein davon
die Hälfte sind für den Erweiterungsbau
des Kanzleramtes vorgesehen wir gehen
genau wie der Bundesrechnungshof davon
aus dass dieses Geld nicht reichen wird
und haben die Bundesregierung
aufgefordert den Erweiterungsbau zu
stoppen leider hat die Mehrheit im
Ausschuss dieses abgelehnt
zusammenfassend stelle ich fest die
Legislaturperiode ist zur Hälfte vorbei
sie setzen falsche Prioritäten bei
Investition und Gesetzesentwürfen sie
haben den die Ernst der Lage nicht
erkannt deutschland braucht Reformen und
eineierung die diese angeht vielen
dankadomsk aus der Unionsfraktion hat
die migrationsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung REM al bado war vermisst
die hat aber über weite Strecken diese
Generaldebatte durchaus verfolgt das MSS
dann auch mal kurz loswerden und hier
geht's jetzt weiter mit a Po ist
stellvertretender Vorsitzer der SPD
Fraktion da zuständig für den Bereich
Haushalt und außerdem ist er noch
Landesvorsitzender der SPD in
nordrheinwestfall liebe Kollegin und
Kollegen meine sehr verhrten Damen und
Herren es ist gut dass wir in dieser
Woche den Haushalt beraten und
beschließen und es ist auch gut dass wir
in diesem Zusammenhang über unser Land
reden über Deutschland über die größte
Volkswirtschaft in
Europa in Zeiten von großen
Herausforderung und wir tun das im Jahr
des 75 geburtstags des Grundgesetzes der
besten Verfassung die wir in diesem Land
je hatten und haben und wir tun das
angesichts beeindruckender
Demonstrationen im ganzen Land
Demonstrationen der Kollege D hat gesagt
der Stärke für ein weltoffenes und
europäisches Deutschland wir tun das
angesichts von Demonstrationen der
Stärke die fürt Zuversicht und
Zusammenhalt kämpfen und wenn ich mal
nach rechts nach ganz rechts in diesem
Hause gucke schauen Sie sich um in
diesem Land in kleinen und den großen
Städten im Norden im Süden und Westen
und im Osten das ist Deutschland das ist
unsere Demokratie das ist die Mehrheit
das ist die Mitte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und lassen Sie und lassen sie
uns lassen Sie uns über diese
haushalswoche reden liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zu jeder haushaltswoche zu
jeder Plenardebatte gehört auch Streit
das auch gut so inhaltlicher Streit
zugespitzter Streit aber zur Demokratie
gehört auch die zweite Seite der
Medaille nämlich Kompromiss und Konsens
und deshalb der Kollege märz ist gerade
nicht mehr da ich bin und bleibe
zuversichtlich liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union dass wir da sie
auch dafür sind das Wachstum in diesem
Land generiert wird ich bleibe
zuversichtlich dass wir was hinbekommen
beim Vermittlungsausschuss für das
Wachstumschancen gesetzt wir sind gar
nicht so weit davon entfernt wir sind
gar nicht so weit davon entfernt einen
Kompromiss zu erzielen also ich setze
darauf dass sie vernünftig sind
vernünftig bleiben und auch hier alles
dafür tun dass wir Wachstum in
Deutschland generieren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und ein zweiter Punkt sie
sind doch auch dafür dass die wrhafte
Demokratie gestärkt wird ich habe keinen
Zweifel daran l sie doch zusammen
darüber reden wie man das höchste
deutsche Gericht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht besser schützen
kann gegen Umtriebe von ganz rechts und
ich bin auch sicher dass sie da auch
nicht einfach Nein sagen werden sondern
sich genau überlegen ob sie mitmachen
oder nicht ich setze darauf dass Sie
mitmachen und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn wir dabei sind wir alle
wollen starke Kommunen wir alle wollen
handlungsfähige Kommunen sie doch auch
ich habe gehört es gibt auch CDU
Bürgermeister und cduürgermeisterin und
auch in der CSU gibt's viele
Bürgermeisterin die brauchen alle
finanziell Mel deshalb überlegen sie
noch mal ganz genau ob sie nicht
mitmachen wollen beim altschuldenf liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und wenn wir
über diesen Haushalt reden muss man
darüber reden dieser Haushalt gibt
Sicherheit
Investitionssicherheit
rekordinvestitionen von über 70
Milliarden Euro liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und dieser Haushalt organisiert
soziale Sicherheit und der
Arbeitsminister wird bald einen
Vorschlag machen um das Rentenniveau zu
stabilisieren und zwar über einen
längeren Zeitraum das ist gut für
Deutschland das ist gut für die
rentnerinen und Rentner und das ist auch
gut für dieses
Land
und kommen wir zu dem was ich vorhin
gehört habe von Seiten der AFD dass man
sich
überlegt vielleicht sogar mehr aus der
Europäischen Union auszutreten dexit ist
das Wort ich empfehle nur einmal ganz
kurz einen Blick nach
Großbritannien von allen Versprechungen
die diejenigen die das Land rausgeführt
haben aus der Europäischen Union es gäbe
mehr Wohlstand es gäbe ein stärkeres
Großbritannien es gäbe mehr
Arbeitsplätze es gebe weniger Migranten
ist ein einziges versprechen ein
einziges in die Tat umgesetzt worden der
Pass ist wieder der Pass des Vereinigten
Königreiches der ist jetzt blau und
nicht mehr der Pass der Europäischen
Union der ist rot das ist das einzige
was sie umgesetzt haben und deshalb kann
ich nur sagen das ist ein Programm der
wohlstandsvernichtung der
arbeitsplatzver und würde Deutschland in
die Isolierung in Deutschland und Europa
und weltweit führen Liebe Kolleg und
Kollegen deshalb kann ich nur allen
raten gucken Sie genau hin was diese
Partei vorschlägt das geht so
nicht und letzter Punkt ich bin
zuversichtlich sicher und zwar bei allen
demokratischen Parteien bei der
Regierung bei den ampelfraktionen und
auch bei der größten Oppositionsfraktion
dass wir in diesem wichtigen Jahr 2024
in einem Jahr der Entscheidungen alles
dafür tun werden dass die Demokratie und
Menschenfeinde verlieren und dass die
wehrhafte die lebendige die tolerante
die liberale Demokratie in Deutschland
gewinnen wird in diesem Sinne alles Gute
schönen
Dank der nächste Redner ist Martin Erwin
Renner für die AFD
Fraktion
ja hochvehrtes Präsidium ich begrüße die
demokratische Fraktion der Alternative
für Deutschland aber natürlich auch alle
anderen Fraktionen hier im Hause vor
allen die neue Sozialistische
Einheitspartei Deutschlands die n SED
die sich hier so gerne als die
alleinigen Demokraten gerieren in
Wirklichkeit aber zu meist gegenteilig
handeln wir sprechen über den Haushalt
der Bundes Beauftragten für Kultur und
Medien der damalige Bundespräsident
Johannes Rau sagte im Mai 2003
richtigerweise wenn wir Kultur nur für
die Sahne auf dem Kuchen halten und
nicht für die Hefe im Teig dann
verstehen wir die Politik und unsere
Gesellschaft falsch der Mann hatte
Recht die Ampel und alle Parteien der
neuen Sozialistischen Einheitspartei
Deutschland verstehen unsere
Gesellschaft nicht nur falsch in
Wirklichkeit wollen sie eine neue
Gesellschaft mit dem neuen Menschen
schaffen ihre Politik bewirkt eine
Unkultur des Hasses der Entmenschlichung
und der Spaltung sie defieren eine
demokratische Oppositionspartei als
extremistische Rattenfänger und
entwürdigen damit auch deren Wähler zu
Ratten oder auch zu Schmeißfliegen
verdausendodukte versammeln das ist doch
ziemlich Strack so eine Zuschreibung
selbst für einen Zimmermann oder
Zwietracht Misstrauen Argwohn Spaltung
Bespitzelung und Verdächtigung das ist
die SA der linksgrünen bolche wen
Unkultur die auch mit den kulturetas der
vergangenen Jahre bestens aufgewachsen
ist nehmen wir exemplarisch die
linksdrehenden schaktivisten von
Korrektiv die wurden im Jahre 2023 mit
600 1000 € aus der Staatskasse bezahlt
Bund und
NRW von diesem selbstnanten Medienhaus
hört man eigentlich nicht viel und
plötzlich kreieren Sie ein Spuk und
Gruselmärchen aufgegriffen und
aufgebauscht durch die klassischen
Mädchen bisschen framing bisschen was
hinzuerfunden und so weiter und die im
Endstadium ihres Niedergangs befindliche
ampelregierung dankte herzlich und rief
sofort ihre Steuergeld finanzierten
ökosozialistischen Apparatschik Apparate
zu Demonstrationen auf Horka wir haben
es gefunden den Stein der weißen und
wieder einmal das Totalversagen der
gebündelen mainstreammien die sich wie
moraliban mit dieser Thematik
beschäftigt haben der über Jahrzehnte
üpig gemessete linksapparat der varia
wuchert in immer größeren Dimensionen
und verteidigt so seine errungene
kulturelle Hegemonie in unsere
Gesellschaft sie haben sicher alle
Antonio grramschi gelesen der hat das
schon so beschrieben meine Damen und
Herren kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss ich
komm zum Schluss es ist hoch an der Zeit
dass alle diese Fördertöpfe im
Bundeshaushalt gestrichen werden und wir
von der Alternative für Deutschland
werden die spülmeister sein alerta
alerta AFD
da Martin Renner war das hier für die
AFD Fraktion nächste Rednerin ist nun
Paula pierchotter sie sitzt im
Haushaltsausschuss hat in dieser Woche
also viel zu tun und ist Mitglied der
Grünen im
Bundestag sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen 2024 ist
auch das Jahr wichtiger Landtagswahl in
Ostdeutschland und deswegen deigt auch
gerade wieder die Frequenz steiler
Thesen zu Ostdeutschland in den
deutschen Politik Podcast die vielleicht
nicht normalerweise bekannt sind für die
größte Ostdeutschland Kompetenz und da
gab's neulich unter anderem so ein Satz
im Podcast Machtwechsel die
Bundesregierung versucht sich die
Stimmen in Ostdeutschland damit zu
kaufen dass sie den ostdeutschen teure
Arbeitsplätze hinstellt z.B in Magdeburg
mit Intel meine Damen und Herren nichts
könnte falscher sein und jeder der sowas
behauptet der hat sich weder mit
Ostdeutschland noch mit der
Notwendigkeit dieser strategischen
chipinvestitionen beschäftigt denn das
was ihn jeder Abgeordnete aus
Ostdeutschland der koalitionstragenden
Fraktion berichten wird können Stimmen
Kaman auch in Ostdeutschland für die
Demokratie nicht mit Mitteln aus dem
Bundeshaushalt
sich einmal erkaufen aber was man
tatsächlich machen kann ist anzuerkennen
dass hier sich Magdeburg und Dresden mit
TSMC und Intel durchgesetzt haben auch
gegen westdeutsche Standorte die sich
beworben haben und aufgrund der
Verfügbarkeit z.B von Flächen und den
guten Investitionsbedingungen von Ort
sich hier diese Standorte durchgesetzt
haben und die Bundesregierung das
finanziert weil es geostrategisch
notwendig ist und wer behauptet dass das
wieder nur ein subventionsgeschenk an
ostdeutsche wäre der verstätigt nicht
nur Klischees sondern der beleidigt und
macht einmal mehr ostdeutsche klein und
das über 35 Jahre nach der deutschen
wiederereinigung und ich finde das
könnte jetzt wirklich mal zu Ende sein
auch in den großen deutschen Politik
Podcast meine Damen und Herren
was ihnen aber die Ostdeutschen
Abgeordneten der koalitionsrangen
Fraktion werden berichten können ist und
es erleben wir jeden Tag zu Hause bis in
die eigene Familie hinein da wo
Prosperität ist in Ostdeutschland da wo
zuzugstatt Wegzug stattfindet da ist
dann plötzlich auch nicht nur die
Lebenserwartung höher in Ostdeutschland
da sterben die Onkel auch in
Ostdeutschland nicht mit 65 am Herz
infakt wie in anderen Regionen
Ostdeutschlands noch viel zu oft sondern
da ist auch die Zufriedenheit mit der
gelebten Praxis der Demokratie plötzlich
höher und dass wir uns deswegen dafür
einsetzen auch mit dem Bittel des
Bundeshaushalts dass wir noch mehr
Regionen in Ostdeutschland haben die
prosperieren das ist nicht nur gerecht
angesichts der Geschichte das ist auch
die ureigenste Aufgabe jeder
Bundesregierung weil die Schaffung
gleichwertiger lebensverhältn ist die
Aufgabe jeder Bundesregierung und das
machen wir in diesem Bundeshaushalt
nicht nur mit Intel und TSMC nicht nur
mit der Unterstützung für Schwed und für
Leuner die wir übrigens jetzt im
parlamentarischen Verfahren noch mal
gerettet haben auch für die fors
regenerativen Kraftstoffen lieben Dank
Müller auch für die gute Zusammenarbeit
an der Stelle aber nicht zuletzt auch
mit der Absicherung des Kemnitzer
wasserstoffstandorts mit zusätzlichen
Geldern fürs zukunftszentrum in Halle
für deutsche Einheit und natürlich auch
mit dem neuen Standort für die dati in
Erfurt das sind alles Punkte wie wir
neue Regionen in Ostdeutschland zu
prosperierenden Regionen machen wollen
meine Damen und
Herren und das ist am Ende auch einfach
nur fair weil dieser Landesteil der
einfach so viel mehrch hatte als alle
anderen Landesteile und ind dem die
Bevölkerung jetzt noch Generationen
später für dieses Pech dieses Pech am
eigenen Leib spürt in Form von
niedrigerer Lebenserwartung in Form von
niedrigerem Wohlstand weil wir einfach
alle gemeinsam diese Aufgabe haben
Jahrzehnte später diese Ungleichheiten
endlich Stück für Stück abzubauen meine
Damen und
Herren es ist heute schon viel über die
aktuellen Demonstrationen gesagt wurden
und wenn sie sich die Karte des
aktuellen demonstrationsgeschehens für
die starke Demokratie anschauen
dann ist das plötzlich eine der Karten
wo sie die ehemalige innerdeutsche
Grenze nicht mehr erkennen können und
das ist neu das ist neu selbst im
Vergleich zu 2018 2018 sie erinnern sich
die Ausschreitung in chemnit Hase du
bleibst hier da gab's danach im
September diese Demo wir sind mehr in
Chemnitz und da hat man es den Leuten
vor Ort noch nicht zugetraut dass sie
alleine genug Leute auf die Straße
kriegen da kamen Leute aus ganz
Deutschland vor allen Dingen auch Berlin
wir fuhren nach chemlitz wir waren an
dem Tag mehr und am nächsten Tag waren
schon wieder nicht mehr mehr Leute in
Kemnitz und jetzt dem demonstrieren die
Leute in Kemnitz genauso wie in
Braunschweig in Leipzig genauso wie in
Essling und in Berlin genauso wie in
Hamburg weil wir auf der einen Seite
endlich in Westdeutschland akzeptieren
dass es kein ostdeutsches
regionalproblem ist die Demokratie zu
verteidigen und weil wir in
Ostdeutschland genug Menschen haben die
sich jetzt trauen auf die Straße zu
gehen da ist Deutschland wieder ein
Stück weiter zusammengewachsen in den
letzten 5 Jahren und es ist ein extrem
großer Grund zur Freude meine Damen und
Herren viele von uns fragen sich warum
müssen wir eigentlich dafür auf die
Straße gehen sollte es in diesem Land
selbst in dem Landesteil wo die
Demokratie nur nicht mal 40 Jahre alt
ist sollte es nicht selbstverständlich
sein dass in diesem Land niemals wieder
jemand auf die Straße gehen muss gegen
Parteien mit
deportationsfantasien und da kann man
das Gefühl haben dass man eigentlich
nicht hier auf der Straße stehen sollte
aber ich möchte noch mal dran erinnern
wir können überhaupt nur auf der Straße
stehen wir können überhaupt nur für die
Demokratie demonstrieren weil in den
50ern in der alten Bundesrepublik
Menschen so klug und weise die dem
aufgebaut haben und in Ostdeutschland so
mutig die SED Diktatur zu Fall gebracht
haben und deswegen ist es auch ein
großes Geschenk dass wir da gemeinsam
auf der Straße stehen können und auch
das kann einem ein besseres Gefühl geben
wenn wir diese Demonstration jetzt in
den nächsten Monaten weitertragen in Ost
und in West vielen Dank soweit Paula
pirchter auch für das nächste Wochenende
sind wieder viele
Demonstrationen angekündigt hier in
Berlin sollen schon 100.000 Menschen
sich angekündigt haben Otto fr spricht
nun der haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
fdpaktion von ihen beschrieben ist und
das selbst wie ich immer sage so ein
ultrawessi wie ich der vom linken nieder
reinkommt an der Stelle seinen
Mitbürgern vor sagen kann seid weiter so
neugierig aufeinander und dann stellt
ihr fest dass bei allen Unterschieden
ihr doch gleicherweise deutsche
Demokraten seid das ist wichtig in
unserer Gesellschaft das müssen wir auch
halten meine Damen und Herren ich möchte
dennoch als haushaltspolitischer
Sprecher der versucht hat mit den beiden
Kollegen in dieser Koalition das
hinzubekommen und ich glaube es auch
ganz kurz hinbekommen hat noch mal auf
ein paar Dinge hinweisen bei diesem
Haushalt der zeigt was diese Koalition
schaffen kann wenn sie ja sich weniger
streitet und wenn sie am Ende nach
schwierigen Vorgaben Lösung findet wir
halten die Schuldenbremse ein wir setzen
die Vorgaben des Verfassungsgerichtes um
die Investitionsquote ist auf Rekordhöhe
in der letzten 10 Jahre wir sorgen
sowohl dafür dass die natoquote mit 2,1
% eingehalten wird wir sorgen dafür dass
bei der Entwicklungshilfe wir mit 0,63%
weit über dem EU-Durchschnitt sind weit
über dem was Vergleich Länder machen ja
ich weiß da gibt es Leute die sagen mich
interessiert nicht was in anderen
Ländern passiert aber ich glaube wer in
dieser Zeit noch national alleine denkt
er muss auch aber national alleine denkt
der wird am Ende auch alleine bleiben
meine Damen und Herren wir bauen
Sondervermögen ab wir sorgen dafür an
der Stelle dass das was abgebaut wird
integriert wird in den Haushalt wir
helfen den Menschen im arteil trotz der
Tatsache dass uns das Verfassungsgericht
nicht mehr die Möglichkeit gibt wir
stoppen den personalaufwuchs übrigens
zum ersten Mal seit 2013 ein
schellmwerer böses dabei denkt dass das
an der FDP liegt wir halten dabei
zugleich das soziale Niveau an der
Stelle wir sorgen aber auch gleichzeitig
dafür dass diejenigen die sich
verweigern entsprechend auch
Konsequenzen fühlen müssen all das tut
diese Koalition zugleich singt noch das
sage ich mit Freude darf ich mit Freude
sagen die Steuerquote und bei all dem
wird immer gesagt aber bei euch selber
macht ja nichts und da gebe ich den
kleinen kurzen Hinweis nur bei den
besucherfahrten die uns allen sehr
wichtig sind und und die ja übrigens
zugleich eine Vermittlung von Demokratie
sind hat der Bundestag dann aber auch
gesagt ja wir kürzen bei uns zweieinhalb
Millionen und bei den besucherfahrten
des Bundesrates die übrigens nicht die
Länder bezahlen sondern die der Bund
bezahlt kürzen wir auch um einhbon das
heißt ja mal klein sein aber wir haben
auch immer geguckt wo betrifft es uns an
der Stelle und ich sage das auch
deutlich in dem nächsten Bundestag der
in dann etwas mehr als na ja zi Jahren
wer weiß mal gucken wie sich das alles
darstellt
kleiner sein wird werden wir auch dann
noch mal an der Frage ein wenig sparen
aber woran wir nicht sparen werden ist
an der Demokratie denn sie ist die Basis
dessen warum dieses Land mitten in
Europa funktionieren kann und Demokratie
ist etwas und da komme ich dann zur CDU
CSU der ein Fraktionsvorsitzender nicht
mehr da ist der ein zuständiger
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitz für
den Haushalt nicht mehr da
ist der steefan nein ich meine den ich
meine nicht den CSU Kollegen ich meine
schon den denjenigen der hier als her
Middelberg uns erklärt hat wir würden
nicht sparen ich will als erstes der CDU
CSU doch mal sagen demtie ist Diskurs
Demokratie ist streiten um die besseren
Lösungen und wenn hier gesagt wird von
ihrem Fraktionsvorsitzenden wir würden
die Anträge ablehnen die Grünen haben
letzte Legislatur über 1500 Anträge im
Haushaltsausschuss gestellt wir über
2000 sie haben die immer abgelehnt und
doch haben wir sie jedes Mal
wiedergestellt und wo sind wir dann
gelandet in der Regierung und da wollen
sie doch auch wieder hin und sie wollen
doch nicht in Wirklichkeit mit leerrheit
hinkommen um dann nachher zu sagen tut
uns alles Leid wir sind zufällig wieder
an die Regierung gekommen wir haben
vieles versprochen aber ist eigentlich
alles ganz anders eine solche Opposition
funktioniert nicht und dann wird gesagt
dann wird gesagt sie würden sparen ich
werde das am Freitag noch mal ausführen
die ganze Liste ihrer Leute die das All
nicht darstellen ich bleibe bei Ihnen
bei dem Schweigen bei Hamlet erster
Aufzug zweite Szene doch brich mein Herz
den schweigen muss mein Mund das tat
Hamlet kund weil er nicht nach
Wittenberg gehen konnte herzlichen
Dank im
Einzelplan ja auch die Ausgaben der
Beauftragten der Bundesregierung für
Kultur und Medien enthalten
dementsprechend tut hier ein bisschen
Zitierung aus den Medien aus den Medien
aus der Kultur gut und nächste redne
Müller für die unionstion Kanzler et
debattieren wir auch über den et des
ostbeauftragten warum eigentlich Ost und
West weil der Osten Deutschland noch
strukturelle Probleme hat und da möchte
ich mit einem Wort des Dankes beginnen
ein Wort des Dankes an die
Berichterstatter des haushaltsauschuss
es dass sie die Möglichkeit gegeben
haben dass die schipfabriken in Dresden
und Magdeburg kommen und unter anderem
die Möglichkeit gegeben haben dass in
Leuna demnächst grüner Treibstoff für
Flugzeuge hergestellt wird herzlichen
Dank
dafür und der WT ein Wort des Dankes
hilt natürlich auch dass das
transformationszentrum auf den Weg
gebracht wird lieber Staatsminister
Schneider gewünscht hätten wir uns
natürlich am Anfang erst eine Debatte
über den Inhalt und dann über den
Architektur wbewerb ich nehme aber
Wohlwollen zur Kenntnis dass am 13 märz
im Kulturausschuss über das
transformationszentrum sich unterhalten
wird und dann natürlich über den Inhalt
des transformationszentrums miteinander
gerungen wird das ist ein gutes Signal
und eine herzliche Einladung an alle 84
Millionen Menschen hier in Deutschland
kommen sie in den Osten unserer Republik
hier geht nicht nur die Sonne auf weil
wo wir sind es von und das werden wir in
den nächsten Jahren auch
beweisen und meine Redezeit knapp ist
möchte ich trotzdem noch ein Dank das
Wort ein Dankeswort sagen an den
Bundesrat der heute bedauerlicherweise
nicht mehr so gut vertreten ist denn der
Bundesrat hat eine
repräsentationslücke geschlossen
ostdeutsche sind in führungsriegen zu
wenig repräsentiert und der Bundesrat
hat bei der Besetzung einer
bundesverfassungsrichterstelle jemanden
eingesetzt und ernannt und gewählt der
an Karl markstadt geboren wurde und das
erhöht die repräsentan von ostdeutschen
und das ist so wichtig dass wir
miteinander zusammenwachsen herzlichen
Dank an den
Bundesrat aber natürlich gibt es auch
Themen und das wäre ja zu schade nur
Danke zu sagen wo man auch die Regierung
kritisieren muss weil es zu lange dauert
und lieber Karsten Schneider ich würde
mir ein wenig mehr eran wünschen bei dem
Thema Ratifizierung des Geldes für die
Pipeline von für Schwed von Rostock nach
Schwed soll Geld fließen dieses Geld
muss ratifiziert werden Schwed muss
ausgelastet werden unser Vorschlag ist
sogar noch weitergehender wir brauchen
eine zweite Pipeline deswegen bisschen
mehr treif mit und diesen treif mitnhmen
damit auch die Kohle und Strukturmittel
gleich retifiziert werden damit wir vor
der Europawahl endlich auch da einen
positiven Haken hinter machen können
dass der Osten weiter Wachstumsregion
bleibt meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren und damit der Osten weiter
Wachstumsregion bleibt lass ich mal
andere für mich sprechen im
Bundeskanzleramt ist ein Brief
eingegangen der Industrie und
Handelskammern aus Ostdeutschland indem
Sie fehlende Einbindung verschiedener
Interessen in den politischen Prozess
bemängeln stattdessen machen sich
eklatante Unterschiede zwischen Worten
und Taten der Bundesregierung breit
heißt es in dem Brief als Beispiel
führten sie den erklar um den
Bundeshaushalt Ende 2023 an außerdem
kritisierten sie fehlenden
Bürokratieabbau und Anreize für
Nichtarbeit all dies führe dazu dass die
internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
Deutschlands leide so alle alle
Industrie und Handelskammern in
Ostdeutschland und das sollte uns ein
wegruf sein ein wegruf VI in diesem Haus
denn das kleine flänzchen was ich gerade
zeigt ist auch bedroht bedroht durch die
Politik ihrer Koalition deswegen rufe
ich Ihnen von diesem Platz aus und zu
kehren sie endlich um beim Planungsrecht
das kost kein Geld wenn eine
Ortsumfahrung wie in Rosslau seit über
30 Jahren geplant wird und nicht gebaut
wird dann macht das nicht nur die
Menchen frustriert sondern es führt auch
zu kein Ergebnis kehren sie beim
Planungsrecht um kehren sie um beim
Thema Bürgergeld wir brauchen nicht
Bürgergeld wir brauchen Bürger in Arbeit
der Ministerpräsident aus Sachsen Anhalt
hat die Bürgerarbeit eingeführt eine
Million Menschen mehr in Arbeit aus
Bürgergeld entlastet unseren
Staatshaushalt und bringt zusätzliche
Einnahmen und insgesamt bis zu 30
Milliarden Euro kehren sie um beim
Bürgergeld kehren sie endlich um bei der
Energiewende es war ein Fehler die
Atomkraftwerke abzuschalten diese hätten
nach dem russischen Angriffskrieg
weiterlaufen müssen kehren sie um bei
der
Energiewende und kehren sie um beim
heizungsgesetz sie belasten insbesondere
den Raum in Ostdeutschland wo wo das
Durchschnittseinkommen bei unter 40%
liegt Kren sie um beim heizungsgesetz
denn dann sind Sie auf dem richtigen Weg
ansonsten haben die Menschen das
Gegenmodell auf dem Wahlzettel im Sommer
diesen Jahres und das ist die CDU CSU
meine Damen und Herren vielen
dank der stellvertrende
Fraktionsvorsitz
derfr
an die ampelregierung stellvertreten für
die SPD Fraktion spricht nun Sonja
eichweder die rechtspolitische
Sprecherin ihrer Fraktion sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin werrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der demokratischen Fraktion wir
diskutieren wahrlich in einer wichtigen
Zeit für unsere Demokratie und für unser
Land es ist angeklung bei den Vorrednern
wir diskutieren über den Haushalt wir
diskutieren aber in einem Jahr in dem
wir auch wichtige Landtagswahlen haben
in dem wir die Europawahl haben in dem
wir sehr sehr wichtige Kommunalwahlen
haben gerade auch bei uns in
Ostdeutschland deswegen ist es doch
gerade heute hier in dieser Debatte sehr
sehr wichtig herauszustellen dass ich
hinter dem Haushalt hinter den einzelnen
Zahlen immer Personen immer Projekte
verbergen die dieses Land besser machen
die diese Demokratie stärken und die
sich für unsere Gesellschaft einsetzen
werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
eben aus diesem Grund tut es sehr sehr
gut und viele Vorrednerinnen und
Vorredner sind darauf eingegangen dass
in den vergangenen Wochen 10tausende
Bürgerinnen und Bürger auf der Straße
waren das wie die Kollegin Paula Potter
gesagt hat man eben keine Grenze
zwischen Ost und West mehr sieht sondern
dass auch bei mir im Wahlkreis in
Brandenburg in Brandenburg an der hafel
in rateno in klosterleninen badbzig oder
in borghid eben auch gerade im ländlich
Raum viele Leute auf der Straße waren
und das ist auch in Ostdeutschland die
Mehrheit ist die hier für unsere
Demokratie streitet und sich für unsere
Demokratie einsetzt mit vielen vielen
Projekten im übrigen auch mit vielen
vielen Projekten die Karsten Schneider
als ostbeauftragter in dem Projekt
machen ausgezeichnet hat im vergangenen
Land das ist ein gutes Projekt das ist
gut für unsere Demokratie das ist das
gut für das gesamte Land und das ist
auch gerade gut für uns in
Ostdeutschland werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es ist wichtig dass die
Mehrheit aufsteht es ist wichtig dass an
den Grundfesten unserer Demokratie kein
Zweifel gelassen wird und es ist wichtig
dass in demokratisch gewählten
Parlamenten eben auch Demokraten sitzen
und nicht solche die die Demokratie
missbrauchen um sie für Menschen
verachtende Zwecke zu nutzen gerade nach
dem Treffen der neuen Rechten und von
AFD Politikern in Potzdam hinsichtlich
der Frage der der
deportationspläne von Millionen von
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger in unserem
Land müssen wir das deutlich machen
Menschenfeindlichkeit Hass Spaltung und
Ausgrenzung ist keine Meinung das ist
keine Option wir stellen uns hier gegen
und das und dass die AFD Fraktion im
Brandenburger Landtag gleich eine Woche
später einen Antrag gerade mit dem Thema
der deportationspläne und den Fragen von
Remigration gestellt hat ist doch auch
bezeichnend welch Geistes kindind sie
sind und deshalb ist es so gut dass eben
gegen diesen Hass der keine Alternative
für Deutschland ist so viele Leute auf
der Straße sind und deswegen ist es umso
wichtiger dass auch wir hier im Haus
darüber diskutieren wie wir unsere
Demokratie wie wir unseren Rechtsstaat
res machen werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir gucken uns unsere Gesetze
an wir gucken nach wie wir beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht und den anderen
Behörden in der exekutiven und in der
judikativen möglicherweise nachlegen
müssen damit eben gerade diejenigen die
verfassungspatrioten sind unsere
Verfassungs schützen und
Verfassungsfeinde nicht unsere
Demokratie unterwandern werte
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
was mich aber sehr berührt hat und was
ich hier auch heute mit Ihnen teilen
möchte ist das am Samstag am 27 Januar
eben am Holocaust Gedenktag Holocaust
den wir auch heute hier im Hause Gedenk
gedacht haben nahe dem Ort in
Brandenburg an der Hafe in dem 1941 die
erste Gaskammer eingerichtet wurde und
9000 Menschen weil sie krank oder
behindert waren ermordet wurden dass wir
eben nahe diesem Ort demonstriert haben
dort umso deutlicher machte was nie
wieder bedeutet dass wir hier eben
unsere Pflicht haben zu gedenken unsere
Pflicht gegenüber der Vergangenheit aber
es ist auch eine Sicherheit für die
Zukunft für eine bessere Zukunft und für
unseren rechtstatt das machen wir in
vielen kleinen Städten in unserem Land
eben auch bei uns im Wahlkreis das
machen wir aber auch mit diesem Haushalt
denn durch diese Gedenkstätte führen
Geiz die selbst eine Beeinträchtigung
haben und zeigen weshalb es eben so
wichtig ist dass Demokratie Demokraten
braucht dass die gesamte Gesellschaft
hier zusammen auch profitiert und auch
durch den Bundeshaushalt mit vielen
kleinen Projekten gefördert wird
Demokratie ist greifbar Demokratie ist
nahber jeder kann mitmachen jeder soll
wählen gehen dann haben wir Bestand so
schützen wir uns seren Rechtsstaat und
das machen wir mit diesem Bundeshaushalt
vielen Dank Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Sonja eich wede eine
Abgeordnete die hier für Brandenburg im
Bundestag sitzt hat hier auch von ihren
Eindrücken der
Demonstrationen erzählt nächster Redner
ist Gottfried kurio für die AFD Fraktion
der innenpolitische Sprecher sehrte
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren der
Kanzler sagte kürzlich die EU-Wahl sei
die Chance ein klares Votum gegen Rechts
abzugeben indem man demokratische
Parteien und nicht die Rechten wählt das
was der Kanzler und andere sich da als
Rettung der Demokratie schön reden
könnte antidemokratischer nicht sein
nicht Extremismus wird bekämpft sondern
alles was nicht links ist dabei sind
links und rechts begrifflich
gleichberechtigte ganz normale
Ausprägung von Parteipolitik aber die
Antidemokraten wollen mal eben die
Hälfte der politischen Landschaft
abräumen denn argumentativ ist diese
Regierung längst komplett blank man
wollte die AFD inhaltlich stellen aber
sie haben nichts deshalb die
verzweifelten Rufe nach Parteiverbot
nach grundrechtsentzug für
Oppositionspolitiker die kneblung
Oppositioneller Meinung soll es richten
Demokratie in Gefahr in der Tat meine
Damen und Herren dafür der
regierungsseitig zusammengerufene
Protest aus der Mitte der linksgrünen
Wählerschaft dafür all die Fahnen der
antifah der SPD der jusus die
schildermann sei Bund die Regenbogen
fahren linke Lobbygruppen gepampert mit
Staatsknete wie pervers ist eine
Regierung ruft zu Demonstration gegen
die Opposition auf lässt erst die
Opposition verlumen und will dann deren
Wähler einschüchtern Hass und Hetze vom
linken straßensturm sollen es richten
zusammen gegen Rechts gegen rechte
Menschen angeblich für Vielfalt de facto
aber gerade gegen Meinungsvielfalt damit
gegen Meinungsfreiheit damit gegen die
essentielle Voraussetzung jeder
Demokratie demokratieen Gefahr in der
Tat meine Damen und Herren so soll auch
die e leus
natürlich mit der Meinung der Regierung
nur Oppositionelle Meinungen
diskreditieren dafür wird die AFD
Forderung nach Rückführung eine
staatspflicht die die Regierung nicht
erfüllen will vorsätzlich politisch
verleumdet alles um die verheerende
Regierungspolitik einer inhaltlichen
Diskussion zu entziehen wer dagegen
protestiert wie Bauern Spediteure
Handwerker der Mittelstand soll nicht
mehr gehört werden wir aber geben weiter
allen Regierungskritikern eine Stimme
Demokratie in Gefahr nicht mit einer
vitalen AFD meine Damen und Herren
Gottfried kurio war das der
innenpolitische Sprecher der AFD
Fraktion für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
spricht nun Lamia Kor sie ist
innenpitische Sprecherin ihrer Fraktion
seh Abgeordnete liebe Zuhörer und
Zuhörer ich glaube der AFD ist es nicht
gelungen das opfernarrativ ernsthaft
stark zu machen die haben sich eher
demaskiert aus meiner
Sicht und andere Nationalisten völkische
oder auch Rechtsextremisten haben ja
tatsächlich die Vorstellung sie könnten
bestimmen wer zu diesem Land gehört und
damit Deutscher ist wer und wer nicht
als ob gelten würde je rechter desto
mehr Deutungshoheit aber in einem
Rechtsstaat wird über Menschen nicht
gnädig der Daumen gehoben oder gesenkt
zu Gruppe der Menschen die deportiert
werden sollen gehören auch Menschen wie
ich und deshalb möchte ich hier
stellvertreten für Millionen von
Menschen Antworten ich bin Tochter
syrischer Einwanderer und Mutter
deutscher
Kinder nein meine Damen und Herren wir
lassen uns nicht von der AFD sagen und
darüber entscheiden wer hier Deutscher
ist und wer hier leben darf oder nicht
nein tausende von Menschen sehen das
übrigens genauso und die sind nicht von
uns orchestriert oder von irgendjemanden
die haben genau das gleiche Bedürfnis
wie jeder anständige Bürger und Bürgerin
in diesem Staat und gehen fast täglich
seit fast dre Wochen auf die
Straße und dafür vielen Dank und das ist
wirklich
großartig denn eins ist doch klar wer
deportieren will will keine Demokratie
keinen Rechtsstaat der will zurück in
dunkle Zeiten dieses Landes und wir
kennen diese dunklen Zeiten sehr geehrte
Kolleginen und Kollegen fast 30% unserer
Bevölkerung haben eine
einwanderungsbiographie wenn AFD und
neue Rechte ernst machen könnten mit
ihren deportationsplänen es sind keine
Fantasien es sind Pläne das ist ein
Unterschied hätte dies katastrophale
Folgen für uns alle und das wäre das
Ende von Einigkeit Recht und Freiheit
und das lassen wir nicht zu und dem
schieben wir auch durch unseren Haushalt
trotz aller widrigen Umstände einen
Riegel vor meine Damen und
Herren wir sorgen dafür dass diese
Demokratie die uns seit über 80 Jahren
Frieden beschert vor ihren Feinden im
Inneren wie im äußeren geschützt wird
fühlen Sie sich ruhig angesprochen wir
werden bald ein
demokratiefördergesetz im Bundestag
verabschieden wir stärken die politische
Bildung und wir ordnen die migrationem
wir
Austausch wir ordnen die Migration indem
wir für Ausgleich sorgen wir sehen die
Herausforderung aber eben auch die
Chancen wir unterstützen das bampf und
die migrationsverwaltung mit
zusätzlichen 200 Millionen Euro und
legen mit 95 Millionen Euro die
Grundlagen für den Ausbau des Ausländer
zentralregisters und wir hinterlegen
Integrationskurse und Migrationsberatung
mit deutlich mehr Geld meine Damen und
Herren und noch eins wer meint jetzt vor
einem akpableger in Deutschland zu
warnen und uns als Regierung Ideologie
vorzuwerfen der hat eines nicht
verstanden alle demokratischen Parteien
wir alle auch wir wir ich wir sie sind
in der Verantwortung Politik für die
ganze Bevölkerung zu machen zumal
türkeisttimmige zumal türkeisttimmige
Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit Nähe mit
politischer Nähe zur AKP in Deutschland
die Union wählen würden wie eine Studie
der Konrad arenauer Stiftung ja selbst
zeigt es zeugt also ein Stück weit von
verfehlter Integrationspolitik und
vielleicht auch mangelndem polit
Adressierung dieser Menschen wenn sie
liebe Kolleginen und Kollegen der CDU
CSU die ihnen politisch zugeneigten
Menschen nicht für sich gewinnen können
und an eine Art deutschen Ager der AKP
verlieren meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginen und Kollegen ich komme zum
Schluss lassen Sie uns daher ungeachtet
des Ringens um die richtige
Haushaltspolitik diese großartige
Protestbewegung auf den Straßen
verstärken und das geht zuletzt habe ich
das selbst in Arlen Westfalen gemacht
Oberbürgermeister Berger hat neben mir
gestanden als grüne wir das nicht
parteipolitisch ausgeschlachtet ich
würde sagen das geht in diesem Sinne
möchte ich gerne heute den Appell mich
dem Appell Anschließen von Marcel Reif
dem sein Vater ihn immer wieder
zugerufen hat ich glaube er ist heute
wichtiger denn
je bleib ein Mensch oder sei ein Mensch
vielen
Dank und die nächste Rednerin ist für
die FDP Fraktion anniko glowski
mer
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin sehr
froh in dieser emotionalen Debatte über
Kultur sprechen zu können denn es ist
uns gelungen dass dieser Bundeshaushalt
trotz enormer Herausforderung einen
klaren und starken Fokus auf unsere
demokratischen Werte setzt die wir
gerade jetzt das merken wir auch in
dieser Debatte gerade wieder mehr denn
je verteidigen müssen und ich sage als
Braunschweigerin danke für 20.000 die
gegen Rechts auf die Straße gegangen
sind und ich sage danke für 1us Menschen
in der priegnit meiner alten Heimat
Haltung zeigen Zeichen setzen darauf
kommt es an in Zeiten in denen ein nie
wieder ist jetzt skandiert und
tatsächlich wieder in den Fokus gerückt
werden muss bin ich sehr froh über
dieses geeinte Signal der Koalition
Erinnerungskultur ist nicht nur ein
Blick zurück auf das was war um daraus
zu lernen erinnern ist Zukunft das was
uns hilft nach vorne zu blicken und zu
wissen was unsere Gesellschaft nie
wieder zulassen darf denn nie wieder ist
immer die letzten Jahre waren immer
wieder geprägt von krisenbedingten
Sonderprogrammen nun müssen wir aber
wieder in den haushaltspolitischen
Normalzustand zurückkehren und auch wenn
die Rahmenbedingungen herausfordern
haben wir als Koalition gerade auch für
die Kultur viel erreicht wir bauen die
Förderung der unverzichtbaren Arbeit der
Gedenkstätten aus die als lern und
erlebnisorte einen wichtigen Beitrag zur
Erinnerungskultur leisten wir fördern
mit 3,3 Millionen eine kulturelle
Aufarbeitung zum Völkermord an den
Jesiden im Hinblick auf die immensen
Einflüsse aus Desinformationskampagnen
und Fake News stärken wir die Deutsche
Welle in ihrem Kampf gegen
Desinformation und Propaganda mit
zusätzlichen 10 Millionen Euro und
worüber ich mich sehr freue ist die
Entscheidung den Kulturpass nach seinem
großen Erfolg vorzuführen durch ihn ist
ein niedrigschwelliger Zugang zuur
Kultur für junge Menschen möglich
Jugendliche die dadurch Kulturen ihrer
Vielfalt vielleicht zum ersten Mal
selbständig nicht erleben
können und was ich hier auf keinen Fall
unerwähnt lassen möchte ist die
Förderung der Games Branche ein
Herzensanliegen für dass ich mich
nachdrücklich eingesetzt habe und
einsetzen werde denn die Games haben
kreatives und innovatives Potenzial
welches sinnbildlich für die Kultur und
Kreativwirtschaft ist kommen Sie bitte
zum Schluss liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in einer Zeit die geprägt ist
von Krisen und Konflikten kann man nicht
oft genug die Notwendigkeit
demokratischer Werte betonen und hierfür
brauchen wir die Kunst und Kultur mehr
denn je denn sie ist eine laute Stimme
der Demokratie ohne Kunst und Kultur ist
alles stumm und dazu dürfen wir es
niemals kommen lassen vielen
Dank Anik glokowski Merten war das hat
an die Bedeutung der Kultur erinnert
ähnlich hat es übrigens auch
Staatsministerin kaudia rot in der
ersten Lesung zu diesem Einzelplan
gesagt und die Bedeutung der Kultur für
die Demokratie betont Christiane
schenderlein spricht nun für die
Unionsfraktion und klegen sobald die
Bundesregierung nach dem Grund ihr
forscherei gefragt wird ist die oft die
Antwort oft schnell und simpel gefunden
16 Jahre CDU lassen Sie mich die
Halbzeit ihre Regierung zum Anlass
nehmen um 16 Jahre unionsgeführte
Kulturpolitik zu
rekapitulieren Verdopplung des
kulturhaushaltes auf über 2 Milliarden
Euro
unbürokratische und effektive
coronahilfen mittels neustattkultur und
den Sonderfond für Kulturveranstaltung
in Höhe von über viinhalb Milliarden
Euro und solide Finanzierung der
Filmförderung dem stellen wir
[Musik]
nun dem stellen wir nun zwei Jahre
Kulturpolitik unter der ampelregierung
gegenüber der jahrzehntelange
überparteiliche Konsens dass an der
Kulturpolitik nicht gespart werden darf
ist aufgekündigt anstatt die Restmittel
von neustadkultur für den Kulturhaushalt
2024 zu nutzen geben Sie diese 300
Millionen EUR ohne Widerspruch an den
Bundesfinanzminister zurück dabei hätte
dieses Geld unserer deutschen
Kulturlandschaft gut getan
unsere unsere großen Kulturinstitutionen
darben die Stiftung Preußischer Kultur
besitzt ist unterfinanziert beim Humbold
Forum wackelt der freie Eintritt dem
Bundesarchiv fehlt massiv Geld für die
Außenstellen des J unterlagenarchivs
beim freiheits und Einheitsdenkmal gibt
es kurz vor fertig ellung ein Baustopp
Finanzierung immer noch unklar der
energiefond für viele kleine
Kultureinrichtungen die ohnehin mit
erheblichen Mehrkosten kämpfen
ausgelaufen sie kürzen beim
Denkmalschutz Sonderprogramm und der
kinoförderung überall fehlt angeblich
das Geld ganz aktuell liefern sie den
Treppenwitz der Haushaltsführung sie
streichen den Musikinstrumenten Preis in
Höhe von 60.000 € um ihren
Bundeshaushalt zu konsolidieren da weiß
man nicht ob man bei dieser Summe lachen
oder aufgrund der offenbar fehlenden
Wertschätzung für unsere Kultur Weinen
müsste nicht einmal ihre eigenen
versprechen können Sie einlösen die
Ampel und Frau Staatsministerin rot
persönlich haben zugesichert
Mindesthonorare für soloelbständige
einzuführen auch hier ist seit dieser
Zeit nichts passiert dafür steigen die
Kosten beim Museum der moderne
inzwischen auf 600 Millionen Euro durch
Mehrkosten für eine ökologische
Nachhaltigkeit am Bau dafür ist Geld da
auch für den Kulturpass für 18-Jährige
100 Millionen Euro es wird auf allen
Kanälen geworben ist ein Vorzeigeprojekt
ja aber mehr auch nicht und am
schlimmsten leidet die deutsche
Filmbranche unter ihrer Politik die
filmverbände schließen sich zusammen
schreiben einen offenen Brandbrief damit
endlich die seit zwei Jahren
angekündigte Reform der Filmförderung um
umgesetzt wird zur letzten Berlinale
haben sie ein acht Punkte Programm
vorgestellt und in zwei Wochen ist
wieder Berlinale bis jetzt liegt noch
nichts vor noch nie war der Filmstandort
Deutschland so in Gefahr wie heute es
ist Halbzeit das Ende ihrer
Kulturpolitik ist in Sicht die Ampel hat
es bis heute nicht geschafft auch nur
einen gemeinsamen Gesetzentwurf
vorzulegen auch beim Staatsziel Kultur
nicht uns die Schuld für ihr Versagen in
die Schuhe zu schieben ist ein reines
Ablenkungsmanöver von ihrer Untätigkeit
und
Uneinigkeit
statt statt ihrer regelmäßigen green
culture Konferenzen hätten wir von Ihnen
gern eine Äußerung zur fabattacke am
Brandenburger Tor
vernommen was man positiv bewerten kann
sind hingegen ihre Worte zum bitteren
Schweigen der Kulturbranche nach dem 7
Oktober und gegen Antisemitismus im
Kulturbetrieb wir sagen deutlich
Kultureinrichtungen oder Kulturprojekte
die mit öffentlichen Geldern finanziert
werden dürfen Antisemiten keine Bühne
bieten wir
brauchen wir brauchen eine einheitliche
Regelung die Dokumenta wirft bereits
ihre Schatten voraus und an Herren
Kollegen Grundel an dieser Stelle wenn
sie als politischer Mandatsträger im
Zusammenhang mit einer
antisemitismusklausel von einer
Einschränkung der Kunstfreiheit sprechen
dann vergiften sie den politischen
Diskurs und spielen den Extremisten in
die Karten wenn sie als Vertreter der
Grünen mittlerweile schon ökologische
Standards zur Voraussetzung von
Fördergeldern machen da muss auch erst
recht gelten keine Steuermittel für
Antisemiten der
Kulturausschuss der Kulturausschuss des
Deutschen Bundestages wird in der
Sitzung am 21 Februar sich mit diesem
Thema befassen wir erwarten hier
Klarheit wir wollen ein vielfältiges
jüdisches Leben in unserem Land ohne
Angst und
Gewalt Christiane schenderlein
verurteilt hier den Antisemitismus sie
ist auch noch mal auf den Kulturpass
eingegangen den hatte sie schon zuvor
als Kü bezeichnet der sich gewidmet
werden kann wenn die Pflicht erfüllt ist
für die SPD Fraktion ist die nächste
Rednerin fr meine Damen und Herren wir
haben Haushalt den haben wir zusammen
verhandelt das waren wahrlich keine
einfachen Verhandlungen aber ehrlich
gesagt sind ja auch die Umstände unter
denen wir diesen Haushalt verhandelt
haben schwierig und damit meine ich
nicht nur und gar nicht mal in erster
Linie das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes denn wir
werden in diesem Haushalt ich glaube in
jedem Einzelplan noch Auswirkung der
coronapandemie finden die
Berücksichtigung finden möch ich möchte
ein Beispiel rausen über 100 Millionen
fast 200 Millionen Euro stellen wir ein
für die long covid Forschung eine
Nachwirkung der coronapandemie die wir
der wir jetzt
begegnen der Angriffskrieg Putins über
die Ukraine an die Ukraine läuft
weiterhin und wir haben mit dem
Sondervermögen das inzwischen zu zwei
Drittel gesichert ist in diesem Haushalt
auch sehr stark abgebildet wie sehr wir
uns um die äußere Sicherung halten und
der steigende Hand
Handlungsbedarf gegen den Klimawandel
der mit Sicherheit auch damit
zusammenhängt dass ich zitiere Olaf
Scholz zu beginnen dieser Debatte sehr
viel liegen geblieben ist dass wir ebeno
einen hohen Investitionsbedarf hat
diesen Handlungsdruck den begegnen wir
weil wir uns jetzt auch trauen im
Gegensatz zu der großen Koalition vorher
dass wir beim Thema Verkehr und beim
Thema wohn da wo der CO2 ausraus am
größten ist jetzt auch mit Maßnahmen
politisch
steuern und meine Damen und Herren darum
ist es gut dass dieser Haushalt eine
steigende Investitionsquote hat das
brauchen wir es ist eben sehr viel los
liegen geblieben aber wir brauchen eben
auch die Debatte über die Schuldenbremse
und ich freue mich sehr dass der
Sachverständigen Rat sehr deutlich
gemacht hat dass auch er inzwischen der
Auffassung ist dass wir noch mehr
Investitionen brauchen dass wir diese
Ausnahmesituation diese multiplen Krisen
die wir haben auch damit begegnen müssen
dass die neuverschildungsquote nach dem
BIP angehoben werden müssen denn am Ende
ist es doch so es wird keinem einzigen
Kind irgendetwas nutzen wenn wir die
Verschuldungsquote um ein 2 oder 3%
Punkte schneller senken dafür aber das
Bildungssystem marode gespart ist und es
wird auch keinem Unternehmer etwas
nutzen wenn das Schienenverkehr das
Schienensystem so marode ist dass die
Lieferungen über den güterfehr dort
nicht zuverlässig ankommen und es wird
auch keinem Arbeitnehmer und keine
Arbeitnehmerin irgendetwas nutzen wenn
sie nicht in Homeoffice arbeiten kann
weil der glasphaserausbau so sehr stockt
und darum ist für uns klar darum muss
für uns klar sein wir müssen über die
Investitionen die notwendig sind die bei
denen es darum geht dass wir gestalten
wollen für dieses Land reden und da
gehört hör nach diesem
Bundesverfassungsgericht auch eine offen
Debatte über die Schuldenbremse dazu
meine Damen und Herren wir bilden in
diesem Haushalt auch
ab das Motto dass Demokratie nicht für
umsonst zu haben ist Demokratie kostet
und darum haben wir beispielsweise und
es ist sichtbar geworden nach dem so
Schwier so barbarischen Überfall der
Hamas auf Israel wie groß in unserer
Gesellschaft das antisemitismusprem ist
es ist aber noch viel erschreckender
deutlich geworden wie rechts extreme
konkrete konkrete Pläne zur Deportation
zur Remigration haben und wie gefährdet
unsere Demokratie mit systematischen
Plänen in die auch zutiefst die AFD
verstrickt ist vorlegen und darum bin
ich so froh dass so viele Menschen in
diesen Tagen auf die Straße gehen und
Flagge zeigen und diese Demonstrationen
sind enorm wichtig diese Demonstrationen
können aber immer nur ein kleiner
Baustein sein sie können nur ein erster
Schritt sein se der Schritt den die
Bevölkerung den die Menschen draußen auf
der Straße machen wir in diesem Haus
haben die Aufgabe und da werden wir
gerecht einen finanziellen Rahmen für
politische Bildung wir haben alle
Kürzungen dort zurückgenommen für
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhaben Halt
und für Demokratieförderung für den
Kampf gegen Antisemitismus als
finanziellen Rahmen
zusammenzusetzen sie eine Zwischenfrage
aus der AFD nein aus der AFD brauch ich
keine
Zwischenfrage und wir werden diesen
finanziellen Rahmen und die Proteste die
wir jetzt auf der Straße haben in dem
ganzen Jahr 2024 zusammenbinden müssen
zwei Bausteine der dritte Baustein der
dazu kommt ist dass wir aktiv als
Politikerinnen und Politiker aber eben
auch alle Menschen die auf der Straße
waren und noch viel mehr aktiv
widersprechen müssen wenn sie am
Arbeitsplatz wenn sie in der
Nachbarschaft wenn sie in der Familie
antidemokratische Äußerungen hören wenn
sie antisemitische rassistische außerung
wenn sie Diskriminierung hören das ist
die Aufgabe der wir uns 2024 das ganze
Jahr alle DemokratInnen und Demokraten
gemeinsam stellen müssen weil es
notwendig ist das ist das traurige aber
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir das
hinbekommen weil wir damit die AFD die
ganz rechts außen und diejenigen die
Hass und Spaltung sehen etwas
entgegensetzen werden und am Ende werden
wir mehr sein wir werden stärker sein
und wir werden es auch länger
durchhalten herzlichen
Dank wieb gester war das für die SPD
Fraktion und bis Anfang Dezember gab es
hier im Bundestag noch eine
Linksfraktion dann hat sie sich
allerdings aufgelöst nachdem zehn
Abgeordnete um Sarah Wagenknecht aus der
Partei ausgetreten sind Pardon und jetzt
gibt es hier eine Kurzintervention aus
der AFD Fraktion der anderen Parteien
von neuen Rechten und der AFD
die Rede und Bezug nehmen Sie auf das
sogenannte Geheimtreffen jetzt mal
abgesehen davon dass D nie von
Deputation gesprochen wde und so weiter
und so fort was ich hier wahrheitswidrig
behaupten was sie hier wahrheitswidrig
behaupten aber ich möchte sie ich wollte
sie eigentlich nur Fragen auch sie z.B
kann ich nachher Fragen aber eigentlich
frage ich Sie sie sagen reden immer von
Rechtsextremen und der AFD von neuen
Rechten und der AFD und jetzt frage ich
Sie sie wissen ja sicherlich dass auch
cduptiker an diesem Treffen teilgenommen
haben und wo verorden sie jetzt die CDU
Politiker also wo verstecken sie sie
sind jetzt die CDU Politiker die neuen
Rechten oder also wie muss ich das
verstehen also letztendlich wie gesagt
cdu-ptiker waren dabei das vergessen sie
bloß immer zu erwähnen und wo verorten
sie die cdu-pitiker sind jetzt Teil der
neuen Rechten weil sie die sonst nicht
erwähnen vielen Dank für die
Antwort die Kurzintervention von Karsten
Hilse war das wollen sie antworten ja
ich antworte gerne und will als erstes
betonen dass ich sehr froh bin dass in
so vielen Reden angesprochen wurde
welche Gefahr von den Rechtsextremen in
diesem Land inzwischen ausgeht dass wir
uns alle in den demokratischen Parteien
dafür bedankt haben dass so viele
Menschen auf die Straße gehen und dass
wir froh sein können dass es eine freie
Presse und ein recherchenetzwerk
Korrektiv gibt die das aufgedeckt haben
und was ich feststellen muss dazu ist
dass all diejenigen nach den Recherchen
die wir kennen all diejenigen die bei
diesem Treffen waren Verfassungsfeinde
sind all diejenigen die bei diesem
Treffen sind tragen die Verantwortung
für diese menschenfeindlichen Pläne die
dort gestaltet worden sind und die
Grenze zwischen DemokratInnen und
Demokraten verläuft dort wo diejenigen
sich davon diszanzieren die sagen dass
das nicht in Ordnung ist und der
wesentliche Unterschied zwischen der
Union und der AFD um das auch ganz klar
zu benennen ist aber dass sie eine
Programmatik in der gesamten Partei
haben die Menschen verachtend ist dass
sie als Ziel als parteipolitisches Ziel
Menschenverachtung Rassismus und
Diskriminierung ausgegeben haben und das
werden wir als alle demokratischen
Parteien in diesem Bundestag bekämpfen
da bin ich mir
sicher soweit noch die Erwiderung und
dietm Bartsch macht sich jetzt auf dem
Weg zum Rednerpult ich hatte es eben
gesagt die Fraktion DIE LINKE gibt es
nicht mehr dimar B ist dementsprechend
fraktionsloser Abgeordnete das könnte
sich am Freitag ändern da dürfte der
Bundestag die Linke und auch das
bündisaravagenknecht als Gruppe
anerkennen namens der Linken ganz
herzlich bedanken für die Organisation
der heutigen Gedenkveranstaltung und ich
will mich auch sehr besonders bei Eva
cpesi und auch bei Marcel Reif bedanken
das waren hervorragende reden und ich
würde mir wünschen dass sie in jeder
Schulklasse einmal angehört werden und
das darüber gesprochen wird das wäre für
unser Land meines Erachtens sehr wichtig
meine Damen und Herren lassen Sie mich
zunächst daran erinnern warum wir heute
überhaupt zum Haushalt für das laufende
Jahr diskutieren das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
Tricksereien der Ampel ausgebremst
Verfassungs widrig war das Urteil das
ist die größte Klatsche für eine
Regierung die es überhaupt geben kann
darauf will ich noch mal verweisen und
meine Damen und Herren im Gegensatz zu
vielen Reden zu vielen Reden die heute
gehalten worden sind ist die Situation
im Lande dramatisch das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt ist im vergangenen
Jahr um
0,3% zurückgegangen in keiner anderen
OECD Nation ist das so gewesen die
Inflationen und die ü in diesem Jahr für
das erste Quartal auch ein Minus
prognostiziert die Inflation war im
letzten Jahr im Durchschnitt bei
5,9% das eine Katastrophe nicht
annäherend bei den 2% die Zielrichtung
der EZB waren das ist doch eine
wirkliche Katastrophe die Lage wir
befinden uns in einer Rezession und das
muss ausgesprochen werden und mit dieser
rezens dafür haben viele die
Verantwortung und wenn der Bundeskanzler
sagt die Stimmung im Land ist unruhig da
hat er schlicht Unrecht es brodelt im
Land das ist die Situation meine Damen
und Herren und natürlich ist es korrekt
auch von der Ampel auf die 16 Jahre von
Angela Merkel zu verweisen aber eins
will ich denn den lieben
Sozialdemokraten und Sozialdemokraten
doch sagen in den letzten 26 Jahren
haben 2 Jahre sie mit Verantwortung in
der Regierung getragen da können sie
doch nicht so tun als wenn die jetzige
Situation mit ihnen nichts zu tun hab
das ist doch nicht der Fall meine Damen
und Herren gerade in stürmischen Zeiten
Bundesregierung die in Haushalt vorlegt
der das Land und den sozialen
Zusammenhalt stärkt und der auf die
Zukunft schaut aber sie tun genau das
Gegenteil sie legen eine belastungsorje
für die Mehrheit im Land vor sie
verteuern den ohnehin schon teuren
Alltag für viele Menschen in diesem Land
und sie versuchen uns hier und den
bürgerinen und Bürgern xvu zu machen das
ist doch alles nicht wahr was sie hier
sagen mein der Bund Bundesfinanzminister
der jetzt auch nicht mehr da ist obwohl
hier eine Haushaltsberatung ist der sagt
äslich der richtigen und der friedlichen
bauernproteste alle müssen einen Beitrag
leisten wenn wir keine allgemeinen
Steuererhöhung wollen das sind zwei
Unwahrheiten in einem Satz die Wahrheit
ist doch sie schonen sich und sie
schonen den Geldadel und natürlich
steigen die allgemeinen steuern ob das
die Mehrwertsteuer heizen tanken essen
gehen Schulessen vieles wird teurer
damit sie ihre Haushaltslöcher stopfen
das ist die Wahrheit alle leisten einen
Beitrag nein eben nicht alle werden sie
den Landwirt nur über den Agrardiesel in
diesem Jahr 176 Millionen aus den Rippen
schneiden wollen haben sie für mehr als
200 Millionen Helikopter gekauft
luxusubschrauber für die Regierung das
ist doch unangemessen wie kommen sie
eigentlich auf die Idee in dieser
Situation in dieser Situation die
Ausgaben für das fürs Kanzleramt nicht
auf den Prüfstand zu setzen eine
Milliarde wird das am Ende werden wir
haben jetzt schon die größte
Regierungszentrale der Welt und da soll
die Fläche noch mal verdoppelt werden
also denken Sie doch mal darüber nach
alle nein eben da wird genau nicht
gespart und dann haben Sie noch die
hutpe dass sie wirklich
11500 neue beamtinen und Beamte
einstellen die Mehrkosten sind 7
Milliarden wir nur ein Beispiel sagen
Frau Geiwitz Frau Geiwitz ist ja die die
für 400.000 neue Sozialwohnung das wird
ja nicht ann nicht mal die Hälfte wird
erreicht aber bei den beamtenen und
Beamten da gibt es ein Plus von 130% das
ist die Wahrheit ihre Aufgaben die lösen
sie nicht aber sich selbstbedienen die
Bundesregierung ist unter der Ampel zu
einem Selbstbedienungsladen verkommen
das ist die Wahrheit meine Damen und
Herren sie agieren vielfach wie der
Vorstand der Deutschen warahn für unsere
Leute muss zu allererst gesorgt werden
ich will mal noch mal dran erinnern 3000
€
Inflationsausgleich für Minister
tausende neue Mitarbeiter was kost die
Welt ist offensichtlich ihr Motto nein
das geht so nicht meine Damen und Herren
und sehr geehr Linder wissen sie der ist
ja nicht da wissen Sie was die höchste
Subvention nach ihrem eigenen Bericht
die höchste Subvention in Deutschland
ist das ist nach ihrem eigenen Bericht
sind das die Ausnahmen für großerben
denn je größer das Vermögen die
vererbtwererden desto niedriger die
Steuerlast nach ihrem eigenen Bericht
4,5 Milliarden Euro kostet das aber das
stört sie nicht Herr Lindner ist der
Vermögensverwalter des Geldadels meine
Damen und Herren das ist die Wahrheit
sie schützen sie schützen diese
Subventionen und holen sich das Geld
lieber bei den Bauern und bei der
arbeitenden Bevölkerung was ist
eigentlich mit dem Respekt von dem der
Bundeskanzler im Wahlkampf gesprochen
hat gewart geworden ja rolf mützenig hat
vorhin völlig zurecht auf das Thema
kindergeldm verwiesen also was ist da
eigentlich los ich meine da lese ich
dann dass Herr Lindner meint dass sie
der dass er den Topverdiener noch mehr
talerzuschussen Schussen müsste mig hat
ja hier gesagt das findet nicht statt na
ich bin ja sehr gespannt was da wird bin
ja sehr gespannt was da wird richtig
wäre Kindergeld für alle auszahlen und
den Freibetrag streichen das wäre
richtig das wäre auch gerechtt und das
wäre auch eine Lösung meine Damen und
Herren auch Politiker tragen natürlich
und müssen nicht alles wissen bei allen
Themen das ist doch völlig klar aber bei
Rente ist so ein Thema was dann doch
sehr viele berührt 21 Millionen Menschen
in unserem Land sind da betroffen und da
liegt es leider nicht die Rente
durchschnittlich bei irgendwas bei 2000
€ und das hat ja rlängst zäht das trifft
übrigens für Bundestagsabgeordnete vor
zu nach 8 Jahren ohne dass wir ein Cent
eingezahlt haben vielleicht gibt's da
auch ein Problem aber für Rentner gilt
nach 45 Jahren durchgängiger Arbeit
bekommen sie ca 1500 € das ist die
Realität die sollte man als abgeordnet
kennen und dann kommt auch noch die
Rentensteuer fast jeder zweite Rentner
hat laut Statistischen Bundesamt weniger
als
1250 € Nettoeinkommen und sie wollen die
Renten in diesem Jahr mit 3,5% noch mal
abspeisen das ist wieder
Einkommensverlust Reallohnverlust das
ist die Wahrheit das vierte Jahr in
Folge weniger im porteme und das in der
stärksten Volkswirtschaft Europas ist
denn das normal unser Rentenniveau liegt
10% unter dem EU-Durchschnitt in der
stärksten Volkswirtschaft da ist was
nicht in Ordnung da braucht's eine
Generalüberholung meine Damen und Herren
ich will nur einen kleinen Mosaikstein
noch sagen machen Sie doch den Weg frei
damit endlich wir alle alle Abgeordnete
verpflichtend in die Rentenkasse
einzahlen wir hatten in der letzten
Legislatur eine Diskussion da waren
Sozialdemokraten dafür da waren grüne
dafür warum machen wir das nicht das
könnte man doch mal machen am Ende
brauchen wir einen Übergang zu einer
Rentenkasse wo alle einzahlen das wäre
dringend notwendig meine Damen und
Herren wir haben in drei ostdeutschen
Bundesländern im herbstwahlen ich finde
es sehr ermutigend um das auch deutlich
zu sagen dass hunderte für die
Demokratie und für Menschenrechte auf
die Straße gegangen sind aber zur
Wahrheit gehört eben leider auch dass
die selbsternannte
fortschrittskoalition mit ihrem Streit
mit ihrer katastrophalen Kommunikation
mit Ihren gebrochenen Wahlversprechen
diejenigen gestärkt hat die unser
Zusammenleben offen in Frage stellen das
muss ausgesprochen werden meine Damen
und Herren sie sind ungewollt zu einer
Werbeagentur für die geworden das können
Sie nicht wollen das können Sie nicht
wollen und ich hoffe dass sie das
Verändern gucken sich doch ihren eigenen
Koalitionsvertrag an kinders
Grundsicherung was ist daraus
bit
Z kommt das nicht mein
letzt wirklich eine horrorrechnung
fürmalverbraucher ist wenn sie nicht
real Umsteuern dann wird so wie iner
Deutschen Bahn und dann kann das Land
entleisen meine Damen und Herren
herzlich
[Applaus]
Dank
wir wiees eventuell am Freitag ändern
für die Grünen spricht nun Erhard
Grundel sehr verhrte frau Präsidentin
ösus meine Damen und Herren
Erinnerungskultur ist kein
Freifahrtschein der auf Erledigung zielt
es geht um einen Prozess der uns
begleitet wir leben in einer
Einwanderungsgesellschaft in der viele
Menschen auch die die hier geboren sind
unsere Geschichte nicht wirklich kennen
es geht darum neue Wege zu finden die
nationalsozialistische Vergangenheit
Deutschlands auch im europäischen
Kontext in ihrer Bedeutung für die
Gegenwart und Zukunft wachzuhalten und
es geht darum dass diese Arbeit
nachhaltig wirken kann und wir sie im
Haushalt entsprechend finanziell
ausstatten Erinnerungskultur ist keine
drogkulisse sondern ein Versprechen an
uns alle an eine menschenfreundliche
Zukunft eine Zukunft in der Artikel 1
unserer Verfassung fest in den Köpf und
Herzen der deutschen Bevölkerung
verankert ist Sie hier rechts
außen für sie ist die Würde des Menschen
eben nicht unantassbar die Würde des
Menschen ist ihnen egal wenn dieser
Mensch durch irgendetwas nicht in ihr
vom stacheldrah eingerahmtes
kleinkariertes Weltbild
passt spätestens seit potdam wissen wir
sie sind Feinde unserer Verfassung
Feinde unserer dem
denn für sie sind Menschen nicht gleich
sondern mit George Orell formuliert
einige sind gleicher als andere wer dazu
gehört das wollen sie definieren aber
das kann ich Ihnen versprechen wir
werden verhindern dass sie hier Menschen
aussortieren dass sie hier Menschen
vertreiben wir das sind die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger auf der Straße das sind die
Parlamente in diesem Land und darum wird
es keinen Schlussstrich unter die
Erinnerungskultur geben denn sie weistß
auf die Mechanismen hin die zu
Faschismus und zur Herrschaft der Leute
ter geführt haben wir alle wissen die
Nationalsozialisten haben sich in
Deutschland nicht an die Macht geputscht
ihnen wurde durch die Unfähigkeit der
DemokratInnen und Demokraten vereinzuh
Handeln der Weg erst geebnet was uns
heute aber bei All Unterschiedlichkeit
ein und das haben die vielen vielen
Menschen auf den Demos der
Zivilgesellschaft in den vergangenen
Tagen gezeigt ist dass wir heute
gemeinsam unsere Demokratie verteidigen
wir brauchen uns die Demokratie nicht
zurückzuholen wir haben sie und wir
wissen wem wir sie ganz bestimmt nicht
überlassen dürfen mit Blick auf diese
Demonstrationen gegen den
Rechtsextremismus in unserem Land ja
auch in niederbeinen und ich bin stolz
in landzut Passau Straubing deckendorf
und Regen fällt mir eine Zeile von Lana
Del Ray ein Hoffnung zu haben mag
gefährlich sein aber ich habe sie vielen
Dank nun ein Zitat von Lana Del Ray also
hier eine große Bandbreite der Kultur
die sich hier zeigt in dieser Debatte
nächster Redner ist trostenfrei für die
Unionsfraktion sehr verehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich bin ziemlich sicher wenn
man später einmal auf die Kanzlerschaft
von Olaf Scholz schauen wird dann wird
diese Krise um den Nachtragshaushalt
2023 und den Bundeshaushalt
2024 eine zesur sein eine zesur deshalb
weil in diesem Moment viele Menschen
auch den Glauben daran verloren haben
dass dieser Bundeskanzler die Probleme
und ihre Lösung vom Ende her denken es
ist angesprochen worden in dieser
Debatte das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts vom 15
November des letzten Jahres das war kein
ein unvermeidliches Naturereignis dass
da über diese Koalition und unser Land
hinwegekommen ist sondern dieses
Ergebnis dieses Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts war durchaus
erwartbar es gab diese
verfassungsrechtlichen Zweifel die sind
von vielen geäußert worden vor allen
Dingen auch vom
Bundesrechnungshof aber der
Bundeskanzler war derjenige der seine
Politik durchgezogen hat wieder
jeglicher Ratschläge und der am Ende des
Land in das die Situation gebracht hat
in der wir heute sind
und wenn man sich dann mal die Folgen
anschaut dann sieht man ja auch kann man
in den letzten zwei Monaten sehr schön
sehen dass diese Bundesregierung auf
dieses Urteil überhaupt nicht
vorbereitet war überhaupt nicht es gab
kein Plan B sie haben lange gebraucht
bis sie sich einigermaßen sortiert haben
und als es dann im 13 dezember war es
glaube ich die
Koalitionsspitzen sich zusammengesetzt
haben zu einem Grundsatzbeschluss da
hat's nur wenige Stunden gedauert ich
glaube keine
24 als sich zunächst einmal der Minister
aus dem Kabinett der fachlich zuständig
ist davon distanziert hat dann drei
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der SPD dann einer der
Verhandlungsführer der Vorsitzende der
FDP und was man an der Stelle sehen kann
ist dass die Autorität des Bundes Kanz
schmilzt wie Eis in der Sonne schmilzt
wie Eis in der Sonne und ich sag das
deshalb weil man angesichts der
gewaltigen Herausforderungen die sich ja
nicht nur in diesem Haushalt abbilden
sondern die sich in unserem Land jeden
Tag zeigen eigentlich einen
Bundeskanzler bräuchte mit Autorität der
in der Lage ist das Land zu führen und
damit auch schwierige und kritische
Entscheidungen durchzusetzen und ich
will das mal anhand von drei großen
Themen beleuchten erst
die Außen und
Sicherheitspolitik die Gefahren die uns
drohen und die Frage wie wir in der Lage
sind uns gegen diese Gefahren von außen
zu schützen und da muss man sagen dass
dieser Bundeshaushalt keine Antworten
gibt auf die Herausforderungen die wir
haben ganz im Gegenteil es gab so einen
Moment drei Tage nach dem russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine als der
Bundeskanzler hier an diesem Pult seine
Rede zur Zeiten Wende gehalten hat da
konnte man den Eindruck haben dieser
Bundeskanzler hat die Situation
begriffen und ist bereit die richtigen
Schlussfolgerungen daraus zu ziehen er
hat hier an diesem Pult gesagt dass ab
jetzt 2% der Wirtschaftsleistung unseres
Landes für die Bundeswehr zur Verfügung
stehen würde er hat gesagt dass es
darüber hinaus ein schuldenfinanziertes
Sondervermögen in der Größenordnung von
100 Milliarden Euro geben soll um große
Waffensysteme zu schaffen und heute muss
man sagen der Bundeskanzler hat sein
Versprechen gebrochen er hat sein
Versprechen gebrochen wenn wir hier über
einen Verteidigungsetat diskutieren der
sich überhaupt nicht verändert hat
gegenüber den Vorjahren der bei 50
Milliarden Euro steheneblieben ist der
im Grunde genommen nur durch die
Zuflüsse aus dem Sondervermögen die
Ziele einigermaßen erreichen kann wenn
es darum geht dass nach der
Grundgesetzänderung im Grunde genommen
nicht große Waffensysteme beschafft
worden sind und werden sondern
einfachste Ausrüstungsgegenstände für
die Bundeswehr dann hat er nicht nur
sein Versprechen gebrochen sondern dann
wird er den Herausforderungen die wir
haben überhaupt nicht
gerecht und wenn man jetzt nur drüber
sprechen würde dass das mit dem Geld so
eine Sache ist dann frage ich mich
anicht angesichts dieser
dahinschmelzenden Autorität natürlich
auch wie die and anderen großen Probleme
bewältigt werden sollen wenn es
beispielsweise darum geht dass wir es
derzeit nicht schaffen die
Personalstärke der Bundeswehr um 20.000
Personen auf
203000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
anwachsen zu lassen wenn wir darüber
diskutieren dass wir die Wehrpflicht
wieder aktivieren müssten wenn wir
darüber diskutieren dass erstmals
Ausländer whrdienst Dienst in der
Bundeswehr leisten soll dann sind es
gewaltige Entscheidungen die
langfristige Konzeptionen revidieren
würden und dann bräuchte es dafür einen
Bundeskanzler mit Autorität um das
tatsächlich bewerkstelligen zu können
und wenn man sich die Wirtschaftspolitik
anschaut dann muss ich wirklich eine
Anleihe nehmen an dimar bsch der die
Lage so analysiert hat wie sie ist und
im Bundeskanzler wenn er da wäre müsste
man zurufen nehmen Sie Ihre rosarote
Brille ab wir haben das doch heute in
seiner Haushaltsrede wieder erlebt es
ist doch schier unglaublich wie man die
Lage in unserem Land gesund beten kann
und ich will Ihnen mal eines sagen das
hat nichts damit zu tun dass man sie
schlecht redet sonder es hat damit zu
tun dass man die Lage analysiert wie sie
ist um auf dieser Basis die richtigen
Entscheidungen für Besserung zu
erreichen und wer beispielsweise noch im
März letzten Jahres behauptet dass die
Investition in den Klimaschutz zu einem
Wirtschaftswachstum wie im
Nachkriegsdeutschland führen würde und
heute sind wir die einzige
Industrienation der Welt mit einer
schrumpfenden Wirtschaft - 0,3% im
letzten Jahr dieses Jahr vielleicht ein
Plus von 0,5 oder 0,6% bei einer
Weltwirtschaft die um 3% wächst da muss
man doch sagen die Vorschläge haben wir
in der Debatte doch elendlich lange
gemacht dann sag ich ihnen Frau es wenn
Sie das mögen dann muss man Bürokratie
abbauen da muss man Steuern senken dann
muss man die Preise für für Strom für
für Gas für energieenken wir sagen Ihnen
doch Andauer dann muss man Arbeit wieder
lohnend machen da muss man für
Gerechtigkeit sorgen eigentlich doch
ihre Themen ihre Themen und wenn sie das
nicht realisieren können dann zeigt es
eben einfach dass sie sich die Welt so
malen wie sie Ihnen gefällt aber es hat
eben mit der Realität nichts zu tun und
deshalb muss man auf dieser
Grundlage also Entschuldigung fr wenn
sie nicht dann ist es Ihr Problem und
sie brauchen uns im Übrigen nicht nur in
dieser Debatte hier zuhören sondern wir
haben die ganz konkreten Vorschläge in
den Fachausschüssen und auch hier im
Plenum des Deutschen Bundestages in den
vergangenen zwei Jahren gemacht unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender ist vorhin darauf
eingegangen wir haben zu jedem Thema
konkrete Vorschläge gemacht die sie
ausnahmslos abgelehnt haben wir übrigens
unterstützen die Dinge die vernünftig
und wirkungsvoll sind und das bringt
mich zum dritten und Letten a das ist
die Bewältigung der migrationskrise hier
bei uns im Land und das hat ja der
Bundeskanzler in seiner Haushaltsrede
auch angesprochen und er hat
angesprochen dass wir die ausgestreckte
Hand nicht ergriffen hätten hat davon
gesprochen dass wir nicht bereit wären
gemeinsam diese Herausforderungen zu
lösen das ist falsch wir waren und wir
sind immer bereit die Hand dort zu
reichen wo ihre Politik dazu führt dass
die Verhältnisse bei uns im Land besser
werden aber das Vorschlagen erau sie
eine Zwischenfrage aus Bundes die grün
bittechön dan Herr frei sie haben gerade
betont dass Sie Projekte Sie sie für
sinnvoll erachten unterstützen im
Einzelplan 60 werden unter anderem 7, 5
Milliarden Euro für die robuste
Unterstützung der Ukraine zur Verfügung
gestellt im Haushaltsausschuss hat sich
ihre Fraktion dazu enthalten wie
bewerten sie
das also Herr
Kollege wir reden hier über einen
Einzelplan im ganzen und nicht über
konkrete Entscheidungen nein das muss
man schon nein das muss man schon
unterscheiden wissen Sie wir haben ja
hier im Bundestag auch auch in der
letzten Sitzungswoche eine ganze Reihe
von Anträgen auch im Zusammenhang mit
dem von Ihnen angesprochenen Thema
gestellt beispielsweise die Lieferung
von Taurus
Marschflugkörpern die komplette
Koalition hat dagegen gestimmt also wir
haben weder in Reden noch in Anträgen
noch in Beschlussfassungen je einen
Zweifel daran gelassen dass wir bereit
sind die Ukraine in ihrem Abwehr und
Verteidigungskampf aber auch im Kampf
für Freiheit in Europa so zu
unterstützen wie es notwendig ist und
deshalb ist es gerade ein gutes Beispiel
wo man sagen kann es ist etwas wenn sie
es genauso sehen und große Teile der der
Koalition tun das ja auch sie
tatsächlich auf unsere Unterstützung
bauen können warum haben
sie und deshalb meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren wir haben in der
letzten Woche ich fahre dort fort wo ich
stehenblieben bin haben wir in der
letzten Woche beispielsweise ein
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz hier
verabschiedet ja wir hätten das
unterstützt da waren ja auch ganz gute
Ansätze drin sie sind aber selber davon
ausgegangen dass mit diesem Gesetz und
deswegen ist es der Name eigentlich ein
Euphemismus gerade mal 600 zusätzliche
Rückführungen im Jahr erreicht werden
können und die grüne Fraktion hat es
dazu noch geschafft zwischen dem
Kabinettsbeschluss undter Verabschiedung
hier im Bundestag dieses ohnehin schon
magere Gesetz weiter zu verschlechtern
und da muss ich ihnen einfach sagen wir
stehen nicht dazu bereit als Feigenblatt
für ihre Politik wenn wir davon ausgehen
müssen dass ihre Politik nicht zu guten
Ergebnissen in unserem Land führen dann
dürfen wir dem auch nicht folgen und wir
haben es heute in der Rede von der Frau
Hasselmann gehört wie sie versucht hat
uns in Haftung zu nehmen für die
Entscheidung für das Bürgergeld ich
komme zum Schluss frau Präsidentin und
es ist ein gutes Beispiel wir haben
versucht das Bestmögliche für unser Land
zu erreichen die schlimmsten Auswüchse
zu verhindern und die Folge ist dann
dass sie so tun als wäre das unser
Gesetz das ist es mit nichten nicht ich
würde im Gegensatz sagen wenn wir die
Möglichkeiten dazu haben dann werden wir
dieses Gesetz wieder abschaffen vielen
Dank am Wochenende hat sich die neue
parteibündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht zum ersten Mal getroffen und
für diese Partei allerdings noch
fraktionslos spricht nun Sarah
Wagenknecht geht hier aus der gleichen
Ecke sage ich mal des Parlaments hervor
wie auch die Linke sitzt die sind noch
relativ zusammen wenn auch nun zwei
verschiedene Parteien
offiziell frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Bundesregierung scheint wild
entschlossen die Zeiten endgültig zu
beenden in denen unser Land für seine
starke Industrie für seinen
erfolgreichen Mittelstand für seine
Erfindungen für seine gut ausgebildeten
Arbeitnehmer und für seine
zurückhaltende Außenpolitik
international geachtet und vielleicht
sogar beneidet wurde statt Antworten
offerieren sie den Bürger Ausreden und
statt Konzepte Schönfärberei das haben
wir vorhin auch vor allem in der Rede
des Kanzlers noch mal ausführlich gehört
und wenn sie dafür wenn sie dafür Zorn
und Empörung ernten dann gehen Sie auf
die Straße und demonstrieren heldenhaft
gegen die Ergebnisse ihrer eigenen
Politik sie sollten sich lieber fragen
was ihre Verantwortung dafür ist dass
die AFD sich verdoppelt hat und immer
stärker wird ja wir leben wir leben in
einer Zeit der Kriege und wir leben in
einer Zeit der kriseen und trotzdem
wächst in anderen Ländern die Wirtschaft
Energie ist bezahlbar Wohnungen werden
gebaut Rentnerinnen und Rentner können
einigermaßen von ihren Renten leben die
Migration ist niedriger und in der
Schule lernt die Kinder sogar relativ
korrekt Rechnen und Schreiben es ist
nicht Schuld der Welt sondern es ist ihr
Versagen dass das alles in Deutschland
heute anders ist
Gas Gas kostet in den USA aktuell ein
Viertel dessen was Unternehmen in
Deutschland bezahlen und beiden stellt
jetzt durch Kappung der
exportkapazitäten sicher dass diese
Preisdifferenz auch in Zukunft
fortbesteht Strom ist bei uns teurer als
anderswo und sie genehmigen den
Netzbetreibern noch eine saftige
renditerhöhung oben drauf tanken und
heizen ist für viele kaum noch bezahlbar
und sie sorgen mit höheren CO2 Preisen
und Mehrwertsteuererhöhungen für den
nächsten Preisschub das ist doch alles
absolut rücksichtslos und wäre während
andere Länder sich aus der Finanzierung
des ukrainekrieges zurückziehen bezahlt
Deutschland inzwischen mehr als die
Hälfte aller Waffenlieferungen aus
Europa und wenn es nach Herrn z und nach
den Waffen begeisterten Grünen und
liberalen geht dann liefern wir
demnächst sogar taurusraketen mit denen
s Lenski dann Moskau angreifen kann und
bringen unser eigenes Land in große
Gefahr was für ein Wahnsinn immer mehr
Waffen für einen nicht gewinnbaren Krieg
aber Kürzungen bei Renten bei Gesundheit
und Bildung wie abgehoben wie
gleichgültig gegenüber den sorgen
normaler Bürger müssen Politik se die
solche Entscheidungen treffen senken Sie
die Energiepreise bevor es zu spät ist
indem wir Rohstoffe wieder dort kaufen
wo sie am preiswertesten sind so wie
andere Länder das auch machen kümmern
sie sich um mehr Lehrer um höhere Löhne
und wieder echte
Aufstiegschancen statt weiter die
fleißigen zu enteignen und sich dann
über Fachkräftemangel und fehlende
Arbeitsmotivation zu beklagen der
Spiegel sieht ihr Kabinett inzwischen
auf dungel
ve die Bürger bin gleich zu Ende die
Bürger wären froh wenn der telspug auch
nur noch wenige Tage dauern würde und
wenn sie auch bei Ihnen die Macht hätten
jeden Tag die schlimmste niet
rauszuwählen vielen
Dank SAR wagenlecht war das und der
nächste Redner ist Helge lind er ist
Sprecher für Kultur und Medien
für die SPD Fraktion Renate bin ich
nicht frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegin
und
Kollegen Liebe Union liebe Frau Dr
schönerlein ihre ja ziemlich
kleinkarrierten gerade zu
apokalyptischen Vision vom Untergang von
Kunst und Kultur in Deutschland die
halten weder einem ftencheck und ich
empfehle da unter ein die Herren Frick
und Rode zu Unterstützung ein weder
einem Fakten stand noch werden sie dem
Ernst der Lage ehrlich gesagt auch nur
im
ansatzgerecht und wenn man dann wie
sie im Ausschuss von Kultur und Medien
im Deutschen Bundestag vor aller Ohren
fast schon zum Fremdschämen das
Staatsziel kulturmig macht und dann hier
uns vorwurft wir würden das Staatsziel
Kultur nicht einbringen dann wird man
nur eingerecht den schönen deutschen
Wort
scheinheilig ich mich aber an diesem Tag
auf das Wesentliche konzentrieren wir
erleben nämlich und das betrifft auch
viele die tätig sind im Bereich von
Kunst Kultur und Medien einen
regelrechten Kulturkampf von rechts
außen der nämlich darin besteht nicht
ertragen zu wollen dass Institutionen
sich öffnen dass wir uns um
Kolonialismus kümmern dass die
Gesellschaft dieses Landes so vielfältig
se ich sich auch im Bereich von Kunst
und Kultur Abbild und wir können ihn
sagen dieser dieser Kulturkampf den sie
erklärt hat wird von uns angenommen und
er wird gewonnen für dieses Land für
dieses Land in der Breite und für alle
Menschen die zu diesem Land gehören und
nicht in Ihrem Sinne wenn man aber
diesen Punkt ernst nimmt kann man auch
nicht wie sie es tun Antisemitismus
instrumentalisieren den das ist das
einzige was sie tun ih geht's nicht um
Antisemitismus wir müssen aber ernsthaft
in dieser Minute über Antisemitismus im
Bereich von Kunst und Kultur in diesem
Land reden es ist nämlich kein
annehmbarer und hinnehmbarer Zustand
wenn jüdische Künstler und Künstler
einem und nicht nur Einzel schreiben
dass sie es nicht wagen sich frei zu
äußern und dass sie es z.B auch nicht
wagen in einem Kulturausschuss offen zu
sprechen weil sie dann keine Chance
haben künstlerisch weiter in diesem Land
tätig zu sein das ist nicht etwas bei
dem wir sagen können das sollte es nicht
geben das darf es nicht gehen und
darüber müssen wir reden und wir können
eben auch nicht hinnehmen so wichtig
differenzierte Diskurse über
Kunstfreiheit sind dass wir die
Kunstfreiheit von Jüdin und Juden in
diesem Land nicht ernst nehmen wir haben
heute gehört durch Eva schppesi und
Marcel Reif welche Schneisen der
Verwüstung von Traumatisierung Schmerz
Ausschluss und Verfolgung Vernichtung
von jüen und Juden in Familien
geschlagen haben deshalb müssen wir
aufschreien wenn es der Fall ist dass
dass die Kunstfreiheit von jüdischen
Künstler Künstler in diesem Land eben
nicht gewährleistet ist das ist die
politische Frage der wir uns stellen
müssen und das sind die politischen
Bedingungen die wir zu schaffen haben
Freiheit muss auch immer die Freiheit
der anderen sehen und deshalb kann es
nicht sein und das ist mit diesem
Haushalt zu beantworten auch mit
nächsten und mit unserer bundeskultur
Sie bitte zum Schluss dass wir bei
anderen Themen immer selbstverständlich
sagen und zurecht gesellschaftliche
Fragen sind zu berücksichtigen bei der
Kunst und Kultur aber bei Jüden Juden
sagen aber die Kunstfreiheit nein es
geht um die Kunstfreiheit derer die
jüdische Perspektiven einbringen wollen
der haben wir gerecht zu Hörden und
dieser Verantwortung werden und müssen
wir uns
stellen Helge lind und wir kommen zum
einzigen Abgeordneten der zwar jetzt
fraktionslos ist aber seit Anfang der
Legislaturperiode fraktionslos
auf nach groenstreng könen wir n
Haushalt für 2024 debattieren und ich
möchte an dieser Stelle zunächst danke
sagen infolge des Urteils des
Bundesverfassungsgericht musste an
vielen Stellen gespart werden dass die
Position für unsere nationalen
Minderheiten etwa im Haushalt von Frau
rot davon nicht betroffen sind und für
die Zusammenarbeit dafür bin ich Ihnen
liebe Kollegin und Kollegen
ausgesprochen
dankbar gerade jetzt gerade jetzt ist
dies ein wichtiges Signal für kulturelle
Vielfalt und gesunde demokratische
Kultur in
Deutschland die Debatten um Einsparung
im Haushalt haben auch bei uns im Norden
die Gemüter bewegt erst soll bei unseren
Bauern gekürzt werden und dann werden
von einem Tag auf den anderen die
Fischer belastet so oder so es trifft
das Land bei uns an der Küste kommt dazu
dass viele weiter mit der Beseitigung
der Folgen der schweren jahrh Sturmflut
im vergangenen Oktober beschäftigt sind
ich habe die zerstörten Orte und das
Leid dass das Wasser der Ostsee
verursacht hat selbst erlebt auch in
anderen Bundesländern Niedersachsen
Bremen Sachsen-Anhalt Thüringen mussten
die Menschen in den vergangenen Wochen
gegen Wassermassen kämpfen um ihre
Existenz zu retten wieder geht es darum
dass der Bund den Betroffenen hilft als
Norddeutscher ist für mich klar dass wir
solidarisch sein müssen Teil unserer DNA
ist es die Ärmel hochzukrempeln
anzupacken wenn Land unter ist gerade
weil Naturkatastrophen durch den
Klimawandel häufiger werden müssen wir
zusammenstehen das uns aus Land als Land
aus was aber nicht geht ist Hilfen
ankündigen und sie dann zu versagen so
wie es der Bundeskanzler gemacht hat die
Kritik wurde selbst von der SPD laut mit
diesem mal hü mal hot verspielen wir das
Vertrauen bei den Leuten und was noch
schlimmer und schlicht ungerecht wäre in
einem Fall zu helfen und im anderen
nicht das wäre Gift für den sozialen
Frieden angesichts des Klimawandels ist
es aus meiner Sicht unerlässlich dass
wir uns als Land besser vorbereiten etwa
indem die Leute sich endlich umfassend
gegen Naturkatastrophen versichern
können bis dahin ist es für mich ein
Gebot der politischen Gerechtigkeit dass
Hilfen des Bundes dort wo sie benötigt
werden verlässlich nach transparenten
Kriterien gewährt werden was diese
Kriterien in einzelnen sind darüber
sollte aus meiner Sicht nicht die
Bundesregierung sondern der Bundestag
entscheiden vielen Dank für
Aufmerksamkeit Stefan se war das vom
südschleswigschen wlerverband und damit
kommen wir hier zur letzten Rednerin in
dieser Debatte zu Einzelplan 4 das ist
die Beauftragte der Bundesregierung für
Menschenrechtspolitik und humanitäre
Hilfe Luise amsbergell für unsere
Demokratie und für ein vielfältiges Land
und ich finde gerade heute wo es um den
Kulturhaushalt geht ist es auch wichtig
dass wir nicht nur darüber reden was wir
nicht wollen sondern auch was wir wollen
und was wir mit unserer Kulturpolitik
auch ganz konkret fördern und deshalb
ist es so wichtig dass wir wenn es um
die Kulturpolitik geht nicht nur uns auf
die großen Bühnen und die zweifelsohne
hervorragende Hochkultur unseres Landes
beschränken sondern die vielfältige
Realität auch in der Förderpolitik
abbilden und ich bin sehr froh und der
kulturstaatsministerin Claudia rot aber
auch Finanzminister Lindner sehr sehr
dankbar für den Kulturpass und vor allen
Dingen dass wir ihn weiterführen denn
erstmalig gibt ein Förderinstrument die
freie Wahl was finanziell unterstützt
werden soll erstmalig wird nicht
vorgegeben sondern nachgefragt und das
ist schon eine kleine kulturpolitische
Revolution meine Damen und Herren
unsere
Kulturpolitik ist aber natürlich auch
auch Ausdruck dessen wo wir strukturelle
Probleme sehen und weil es noch immer zu
wenig Frauen auf und hinter den Bühnen
sind freue ich mich dass wir mit mewem
ein kleines aber sehr Wichtiges
mentoringpjekt für Frauen in der
Musikwirtschaft finanzieren weil es
sozusagen auch eine Unterstützung im
Bereich der amateurmusik braucht haben
wir mit dem
amateurmikfond das kulturelle Ehrenamt
gestärkt in der Stadt und auch auf dem
Land die Räume die Menschen zu
musizieren und für ihre
Professionalisierung auch brauchen
erstmals fördern wir die riesige
popkulturelle Festivalszene finde ich ja
wirklich das großartigste an diesem
Haushalt in unserem Land schon jetzt ist
dieser Fond um ein fünffaches
überzeichnet was für ein Erfolg und
liebe Claudia wirklich was für ein
klares Zeichen dafür dass wir hier genau
richtig lagen was die Bedarfe
jetzt müssen wir die mittelzügig
entsperren denn für den kommenden Sommer
brauchen die Festivals
Planungssicherheit der schaltschutzfond
wird die Clubs in lärmkonflikten mit
Investitionen in den Lärmschutz
unterstützen das ist ein weiteres
Versprechen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
dass wir jetzt umsetzen aber meine Damen
und Herren wenn man über Kulturpolitik
redet muss man auch das erwähnen das
Clubsterben werden wir nicht mit Geld
aufhalten können das Molotov in Hamburg
Destillery in Leipzig Harry kleinen
München einige Clubs sterben laut manche
leise und das so ehrlich müssen wir sein
würden wir in der Hochkultur niemals
zulassen Clubs aber sind Kulturorte
Schutzräume gerade in dieser Zeit extrem
wichtig Orte der kreativen Entfaltung
und des Ausprobierens und desher braucht
es rechtlichen Rahmen Rahmenbedingungen
die das stärken und hier liegt natürlich
die Verantwortung in der baau
nutzungsverordnung und der TA Lärm hier
sind wir als Regierungsfraktion das sage
ich auch so offen noch in der Pflicht
und hier müssen wir noch liefern aber
meine Damen und Herren ich habe das zu
Beginn gesagt Kulturpolitik ist
existentiell für unsere Gesellschaft
existentiell auch genau diese Räume und
Orte zu schützen denn Kultur ist
Ausdruck des menschlichen Daseins des
Menschseins am Ende und ich bin stolz
darauf dass wir es geschafft haben in
diesem Haushalt diesem Anliegen das auch
abzubilden ein Stück näher zu kommen
also vielen Dank auch für deine Arbeit
Claudia und dafür dass du diese Vielfalt
und vor allen Dingen auch das Potential
und die kulturelle schaffenkraft
Schaffenskraft in unserem Land auch
siehst das stärkst und uns da als
Parlament auch so eine gute Leitlinie
bist vielen
[Applaus]
Dank ich schließe die Aussprache wir
kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Einzelplan 04 Bundeskanzler und war also
nun hier die Debatte zum Einzelplan des
Bundeskanzler Bundeskanzler
die abordneten werden darüber jetzt
namentlich abstimmen in der westlobby so
ist es ja Usus und in dieser Debatte
wurde ja auch viel über die
Demonstrationen berichtet die sich gegen
Rechtsextremismus im Land entfacht haben
nachdem klar wurde dass in Potzdam
mehrere rechtsextreme sich getroffen
haben und auch aufd Politiker um über
die massenhafte Abschiebung von Menschen
zu diskutieren entweder ein
Migrationshintergrund haben oder sich
z.B für eine offene Gesellschaft
einsetzen mit dabei war hier auch Geri
die wir hier in der Debatte sehen eine
AFD Abgeordnete sie hat sich nun aber
nicht hier in der Debatte geäußert und
auch Nachfragen von Kollegen zu eben
diesem
Treffen auf die ist sie leider nicht
eingegangen hat aber der Süddeutschen
Zeitung ihre Teilnahme an dem Treffen
bestätigt also wir werden dort wahrchein
noch in Zukunft mehr zu hören auch das
wurde hier in der Debatte
angekündigt und begrüßt das ja auch am
nächsten Wochenende wieder viele
Demonstrationen geplant werden und hier
um den Bundestag um das
reichsgebäude da soll es eine
Menschenkette geben um eben auch gegen
Rechtsextremismus zu demonstrieren